[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat pour cette
huitième journée de débat sur la réforme
des retraites ici au Sénat les équipes
de Public Sénat restent mobilisées pour
vous faire vivre ses échanges toute la
journée et toute la soirée en direct sur
notre antenne et aussi sur notre site
internet public sénat.fr vous serez
aussi également directe de la tribune de
l'hémicycle du Sénat avec Steve Jourdain
qui va commenter ses débats on le
rappelle l'information de la soirée
d'hier c'est que le Sénat a enfin voté
l'article 7 sur le report de l'âge légal
de départ à 64 ans article essentiel de
cette réforme des retraites et ce matin
les débats vont être directement très
intéressant très important puisque les
sénateurs vont discuter de l'amendement
du président du groupe les républicains
anciennes à Bruno Retailleau qui veut
accélérer la suppression des régimes
spéciaux qui est prévu par cette réforme
des retraites une réforme de retraite
qui contient la clause du grand-père
c'est à dire que seulement elle est
salarié entrant dans les entreprises
concernées par ces régimes spéciaux
seront concernés par leur suppression et
Bruno Retailleau veut supprimer cette
clause du grand-père alors on a entendu
que les débats commencent véritablement
sur ces régimes spéciaux on va peut-être
rejoindre Steve Jourdain en tribune de
l'hémicycle du Sénat Steve le Sénat au
théière enfin à cet article 7 mais les
débats ont été tendus oui Alex 15 heures
de débat 15h et bien de galipette
procédurale 15 heures de débat très
mouvementée au terme desquels
effectivement l'article 7 a été adopté
le Sénat qui a donc donné son feu vert à
la retraite à 64 ans 15 heures de débat
qu'on a pu suivre en direct en
intégralité sur Public Sénat et au cours
desquelles et ben on a découvert
certains trésors de la procédure
législative avec notamment l'utilisation
de cet article 38 bien du Règlement du
Sénat c'est un titre qui permet de
limiter le temps de parole par article
ou par amendement il a été dégainé par
la droite qui souhaite accélérer
l'examen de cette réforme qui souhaite
et bien que ce projet loi soit adopté
d'ici à dimanche soir la gauche
évidemment si est opposée on verra si
cet article sera à nouveau dégainé dans
les prochaines heures alors sur cet
article 7 Alex l'hémicycle se divise
c'est divisé au moment du vote un peu
schématiquement en deux avec sans
surprise une droite qui a très largement
voté en faveur de la retraite à 64 ans
sur 145 votants seuls 2 seul 2 sénateurs
LR ont voté contre et de l'autre côté de
l'hémicier qui avait la gauche à voter
comme un seul homme contre la retraite à
64 ans la gauche qui est composée de
trois groupes les écologistes les
socialistes et les communistes place
maintenant vous l'avez dit à aux
articles qui suivent donc l'article 7
très article sont encore à examiner
d'ici à dimanche on va suivre notamment
l'amendement de Bruno retaillod que vous
avez évoqué Alex cet amendement qui
prévoit une 10 à disparition des régimes
spéciaux une disparition que la droite
veut plus rapide que le gouvernement la
séance a donc s'annonce donc très
mouvementée on va suivre ça bien sûr en
direct sur Public Sénat merci beaucoup
Steve allez la direction l'hémicycle du
Sénat pour la suite des débats sur la
réforme des retraites
de du Sénat je demande monsieur le
Président la réserve de l'examen de
l'amendement 2057 après l'article 13
selon l'article 44 alinéa 6 du règlement
la réserve est de droit quand elle lui
demandait par la Commission saisie au
fond ce qui vient d'être le cas sauf
opposition du gouvernement avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente de la Commission Madame et
Monsieur le rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je l'ai dit de
manière systématique depuis le début de
vos travaux et de nos débats le
gouvernement ne s'oppose jamais à la
Commission pour ce qui concerne les
questions de recevabilité du
recevabilité ou d'organisation des
débats donc la vie est bien évidemment
favorable
la réserve est donc ordonnée
et donc chers collègues
la discussion des amendements va
reprendre
au niveau de l'amendement numéro 608
rectifié bis de Madame qu'on cogne si je
peux terminer ma phrase j'ai reconnu
pardon mais l'ordre des débats un comble
à la présidence quel que soit celui qui
l'exerce
donc la discussion reprendra à
l'amendement 608 si vous voulez bien
vous y reporter et s'il y a une
un rappel au règlement il est le
bienvenu
monsieur le Président canner
merci monsieur le Président mais je vous
rassure je n'étais pas irrespectueux à
l'égard de votre responsabilité je vous
laisse vérifier que vous avez bien vu
mon rappel au Règlement
sur la base de l'article 44 bis
concernant le droit d'amendement des
parlementaires
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
nous avons vu quand même au travers de
cette réserve alors que nous préparions
tous à batailler à ferrailler
naturellement sur un amendement qui est
très important qui est d'ailleurs nous
voulions voir aborder plutôt dans le
débat parlementaire notamment sur la
partie recette
et voilà par surprise je ne dirais pas
des Loyauté ce serait trop fort mais par
surprise alors que Monsieur Retailleau
hier nous a fait une très grande
diatribe en disant vous les obstructeurs
je résume et bien vous utilisez vous
utilisez les arguties pour ne pas aller
au débat ce matin je tiens à le dire
nous étions prêts nous étions prêts à
ferrailler monsieur le Président du
Groupe LR et aujourd'hui vous décalez
votre intervention je trouve cela
vraiment extrêmement déloyale
à l'égard du bon déroulement de nos
travaux et la sincérité de nos débats
est toujours très importante y compris
par rapport à d'éventuels recours devant
le Conseil constitutionnel donc nous
sommes prêts je vous rassure même après
l'article 13 nous feraillerons contre
cette Amanda amendement qui est
totalement inique injuste notamment pour
les travailleurs de ces entreprises qui
vont être supprimées en termes de
retraite merci à vous
très bien monsieur le Président
Retailleau pour un autre rappel au
règlement
que celui qu'a utilisé mon collègue
président du groupe bien sûr que nous
allons discuter de la norme manque j'ai
déposé simplement je voudrais porter à
votre connaissance chers collègues que
au moment où je vous parle hier c'était
le président l'archet dans la permanence
était privée d'électricité et ceux qui
ont fait cela et ceux qui ont fait cela
et ceux qui ont fait cela ont aussi
coupé l'électricité d'une clinique au
moment où je vous parle d'autres
sédataires ont vu à leur domicile à leur
entreprise l'électricité coupée au
moment où je vous parle
j'attends je n'accuse personne
mes chers collègues
gardez votre calme
j'attends de la gauche qu'elle dénonce
aussi unanimement ces agissements
unanimement ce sont des violences qui
sont faites à des élus de la République
et il y a là comme une appropriation
partisanée personnelle des moyens de
production d'énergie qui appartiennent
au peuples français et non pas à tel ou
tel Corporation
[Applaudissements]
madame Brulin à la parole pour un rappel
au règlement
si monsieur le Président
mon rappel au règlement se fonde sur le
même article et je voudrais interroger
nos collègues des républicains avez-vous
la réforme et votre soutien au
gouvernement honteux ce matin vous avez
multiplié les procédures pour que
l'article 7 soit voté en pleine nuit
il s'en est fallu de deux nuits pour
qu'il soit adopté et aujourd'hui vous
voulez retarder l'examen d'un article
qui suscite beaucoup de colère dans
notre pays ce que vous avez évoqué
monsieur Retailleau témoigne précisément
de la colère que suscite votre
amendement et vous voulez l'examiner
loin du regard de nos concitoyens qui
sont les premiers concernés
je
considère que cet amendement doit être
discuté en plein jour ainsi que les sous
amendements que nous avons déposés parce
que voyez-vous
ce dont nous parlons ça n'est pas
d'obstruction ou de sous amendements que
vous considérez inutile c'est de
regarder concrètement précisément métier
par métier ce que votre amendement va
induire pour des travailleurs dont les
conditions de travail sont extrêmement
difficiles
je pense que monsieur le Président il
faudrait faire une suspension de séances
pour que chaque groupe puisse
réorganiser son travail à partir de ce
qui vient d'être proposé et je pense que
le report de l'examen de l'amendement du
président retaillau doit permettre à la
commission des affaires sociales
d'examiner de manière approfondie c'est
sous amendement ce qui n'a pour
l'instant pas été le cas sur les sous
amendements déposés par les groupes de
gauche ces dernières heures
monsieur le Président Gontard a la
parole pour un autre et pensons-nous
ultime rappel au règlement
sur l'article 38 Alina 8 d'abord pour
rappeler quand même que le rappel au
règlement de du président Retailleau
était totalement hors sujet qu'on n'est
pas là pour non il était totalement hors
sujet par rapport à ce qui est en train
de se passer deuxièmement par rapport à
cette amendement moi je rappelle quand
même que hier soir on a arrêté la séance
prématurément parce qu'il est resté du
temps parce que je crois que Monsieur
Retailleau était déjà parti donc on a
cru comprendre qu'on a arrêté la séance
pour pouvoir examiner l'amendement de
Monsieur Retailleau et puis on arrive ce
matin et puis on s'aperçoit que cet
amendement du coup on le repousse de
quoi avez-vous peur pourquoi cette
désertion
parlons-en parlons-en c'est un sujet
important on est d'accord parlons-en
remettez-le et qu'on puisse discuter
dans le fond depuis le début vous
refusez de le débat vous refusez
discuter vous nous avez corseté vous
nous avez enfermé dans un débat je
dirais à sens unique et vous continuez
vous continuez comme ça
franchement un peu de courage remettez
cette amendement qu'on puisse débattre
tranquillement merci
la parole est à monsieur n'est pas le
Savary
oui je crois que
ce débat sur la retraite mérite
véritablement
que nous soyons attentifs et pas
provocateur les uns par rapport aux
autres
en conséquence mes chers collègues
vous avez sacrifié me semble-t-il à
travers votre volonté d'obstruction
disons-le de présenter de présenter des
amendements
pour lequel l'objet n'était pas d'une
qualité à la hauteur de nos débats me
semble-t-il et qui ne correspondait pas
surtout à vos interventions vous savez
souhaité depuis des heures et des heures
manifester votre hostilité à cette
réforme on l'a bien compris mais pendant
ce temps-là nous n'avons pas nous
n'avons pas entamé le débat de fond et
maintenant vous reprochez vous reprochez
que nous soyons en retard par rapport à
ce débat alors réfléchissez bien il vous
appartient d'être attentif de pas
forcément mettre des sous amendements
par rapport aux amendements que nous
proposons et qui va encore retarder le
débat c'est la raison pour laquelle je
vous invite mes chers collègues à être
attentif à tout cela et bien réfléchir
que nous avons véritablement des sujets
importants qui méritent encore des
heures de discussion et nous souhaitons
vivement aborder cette discussion merci
donc nous allons ouvrir la discussion
sur l'amendement 608 est-ce que monsieur
Lurel peut le présenter puisqu'ils le
seul signataire présent
l'amendement 608
il y a déjà eu il y a déjà eu des repas
le règlement pour chaque groupe
madame la Présidente rossignol
à votre président
tout en admettant bien volontiers que
c'est vous qui présidez personne d'autre
néanmoins l'article 36 précise que la
parole est accordée sur le champ à tous
sénateurs qui la demande pour un rappel
aux règlements l'auteur doit simplement
faire référence à un article du
règlement donc je vous invite monsieur
le Président a appliquer cet article 36
alinéa 3 et a donné la parole au
collègue qu'il la demande pour des
rappels au règlement
je ne vous avais pas vu et donc ça
aurait été plus simple merci monsieur
auquel je fais référence et l'article 33
qui traite notamment des attaques enfin
du comportement dans l'hémicycle le
président Bruno Retailleau a rapporté
des faits extérieurs à notre hémicycle
mais les a rapportés en s'adressant
manifestement directement au président
kaner nous nous bataillons fermement
contre cette réforme nous utilisons ce
des outils que le règlement nous accorde
nous l'opposition mais nous ne sommes en
aucune manière responsable des faits
tout à fait regrettable et parfois
délictueux que le président Retailleau a
rapporté et parfois des luxueux que le
président Retailleau a rapporté il
serait bon que ces attaques personnelles
qui sont proscrites par l'article 33 de
notre règlement n'est pas lieu dans
cette hémicycle vous portez une réforme
nous l'avons compris vous l'avez conçu
cette réforme vous l'avez confiée au
gouvernement c'est un peu une gestation
pour autrui que vous avez fait une
gestation pour le gouvernement
et
l'accouchement est un peu difficile nous
en convenons retrouvons notre calme
cessons ces attaques et appliquons les
articles de notre règlement je vous
remercie
c'est donc ce que nous allons pouvoir
faire quel est l'orateur qui veut
défendre l'amendement numéro 608
rectifié bis
madame a poursuit
merci monsieur le Président donc se
rappelle au règlement
que le 44 bis ma collègue colline Brulin
vient de vous demander une suspension de
séance je crois que ça serait normal de
nous l'accorder parce que l'amendement
de Monsieur Retailleau devait venir hier
soir il n'est pas arrivé il venait il
devait venir ce matin il n'est toujours
pas là et maintenant monsieur Retailleau
nous propose donc de discuter en
catimini ce soir de cet amendement et
donc ce n'est pas possible nous vous le
disons depuis le début nous ne faisons
pas d'obstruction nous défendons pieds à
pied la réforme des retraites
c'est vous qui êtes l'obstruction
l'obstruction au peuple l'obstruction
aux gens qui défilent dans la rue et qui
combattent votre réforme et c'est pour
ça que cette nuit vous nous avez fait
voter en catimini l'article 7 parce que
vous êtes vous avez honte finalement de
ce que vous êtes en train de faire alors
on a on a eu le tour Monsieur
nos amendements finalement n'ont pas
n'ont pas été la fois passée ils n'ont
pas ils ne sont pas venus en commission
des affaires sociales c'était un
simulacre démocratie alors nous
demandons de réunir la commission des
affaires sociales que Monsieur
Retailleau puisse déposer son amendement
comme c'était prévu ce matin dans
l'ordre du jour que nous puissions
réunir la commission des affaires
sociales pour discuter de nos
sous-amendements monsieur lévrier
également pour un rappel au règlement je
suppose
oui merci monsieur le Président un
rappel règlement sur les mêmes
fondements et en réaction à ma collègue
à poursaut poli j'entends bien ça
demande de
d'arrêt pour quelques minutes pour
réorganiser son travail je sais mais
qu'il se pose la même question en posant
en autant d'amendements en catimini
cette nuit pour les autres groupes qui
ne les découvrent ce matin et et je
rappelle je rappelle que l'hypocrisie a
été soulevée élevée hier sur les
discussions qu'il y a pu avoir en
réunion des présidents où il est très
clair que l'obstruction a été clairement
annoncé ici et que donc vous devez
l'assumer maintenant ça sera beaucoup
plus simple et ça nous évitera de perdre
un temps fou donc moi je maintiens je
suis désolé que nous mon contenu aux
travaux et que travailler la nuit fait
partie de notre mission et qu'il est
étonnant que vous parliez de Catimini
quand on nous travaillons la nuit c'est
notre rôle à tous il n'y a aucun aucun
changement d'un vote de nuit comme d'un
vote de jour ou alors demandé que les
séances s'arrêtent à 6h du soir comme de
bon de bonnes personnes qui doivent
travailler la nuit merci toujours pour
la commission
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le rapporteur la commission est
disponible jour et nuit mais Cathy a
pour ce poli
entreprendre du temps et précipiter il y
a une différence parce que vous nous
proposez que l'amendement de Bruno
retailleux a discuté ce soir comme il a
été convenu de le replacer après
l'article 13 ce sera cela voudrait dire
que nous ayons eu le temps de débattre
de tous les articles d'ici ce soir c'est
pas du tout le cas c'est pas du tout le
cas je ne pense pas ou alors vous avez
une volonté là de bâcler entre bâclés
d'un côté le débat et puis l'empêcher il
y a peut-être une marge de manœuvre qui
nous permettrait de rentrer un peu dans
le fond des choses moi j'attire votre
attention quand même
vous avez une volonté d'opposition
d'accord mais ceux qui ont la volonté de
débattre les Français l'attendent
permettaient quand même que le Parlement
puisse jouer son rôle en conséquence
réviser vos arguments d'opposition quand
même au moins qu'il tienne au moins
qu'ils tiennent ils ne tiennent pas donc
soyez attentif à cela quand même nous
n'avons jamais eu l'habitude de
travailler comme ça il y a toujours eu
un respect dans le baobabad
confrontation qui est nécessaire au
Parlement
convenait en donc ressaisissez-vous et
faites en sorte qu'on puisse enfin
débattre
[Applaudissements]
le rapporteur s'est exprimé avec la
sentiment de la présidente de la
commission
ce qui conduit donc à ce que nous
poursuivions le débat et Monsieur Durin
est appelé et convié à bien vouloir
présenter l'amendement 608 rectif les
vis dont il est le signataire après bien
entendu que Madame ponce nous aurait
éclairé sur son interprétation du
règlement
et bien monsieur le Président votre
phrase introductive est totalement dans
l'objet de mon intervention
parce que je suis une sénatrice récente
mais après les
retours
rappelle au règlement de Monsieur
Retailleau et de Monsieur lévrier
vraiment pour moi c'est complètement
sans objet je compte alors donc
effectivement c'est plutôt moi qui
demande à être éclairé je comprends que
Monsieur retaillé au le matin
des 10h30 et besoin de sa dose
idéologique son discours il y en a qui
prennent de la vitamine C oui il y en a
qui prennent de la vitamine C vous vous
avez besoin de vous injecter des doses
idéologiques très tôt le matin pour vous
donner de la force très bien mais oui
mais en quoi les coupures d'électricité
en quoi les coupures d'électricité
étaient un objet du rappel au règlement
vous me l'expliquerez et puis arrêtez de
dire qu'on veut pas aller au débat de
fond
le débat de fond c'était hier c'était
l'article 7 que vous avez restreint
effectivement parce que effectivement si
je suis le maillot jaune vous n'étiez
pas dans le peloton et donc et donc oui
le débat de fond nous le voulions les
syndicats le voulaient on avait 5 jours
il voulait bien qu'on passe au moins
deux jours sur l'article 7 mais vous ça
vous intéressait pas ce qui vous
intéresse c'est les autres articles
c'est de montrer qu'il y a quelques
mesures d'accompagnement voilà
ça c'est pas moi c'est pas moi rappelle
au règlement que celui de Monsieur
bataillon
merci Madame maintenant la parole est à
Monsieur dur sur l'amendement 608
rectifié bis
merci monsieur le Président
le projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale qui
porte réforme du système de retraite ne
contient à ce stade aucune mesure
spécifique concernant l'adite outre-mer
pourtant notre situation est très
différente notre situation je parle au
nom des collègues qui ont déposé
l'amendement de celle de l'Hexagone en
raison de l'arrivée tardive de la
sécurité sociale dans nos territoires et
de la persistance tiers à notre histoire
d'une part importante de travail un
formel ou de défaut de déclaration les
carrières hachées sont de ce fait sur
représentés dans les outre-mer et très
difficile à reconstituer faute
d’archives complètes il en ressort un
niveau de pension de base sensiblement
plus bas que dans l'Hexagone et un
nombre très important de retrait pauvre
voire très pauvre les données repères de
la sécurité sociale nous donne à ce
titre des chiffres éclairants l'âge
moyen du départ à la retraite en
Martinique et de 65,3 ans contre 62,9
ans au niveau national en raison d'un
nombre de trimestres validés plus
difficile à atteindre pour les
Martiniquais cela est confirmé par une
étude menée sur la génération 61 64 par
la Sécurité Sociale
6,5% des assurés de cette génération
sont partis à la retraite au niveau
national contre moins de 1% en
Martinique un peu plus de 6% des assurés
de cette génération sont concernés par
des trous de carrière en France contre
20% Martinique les validités incomplètes
sont largement supérieures en Martinique
concernant les départs anticipés là
aussi des différences sont notables il
concerne 2% des assureurs en Martinique
en 2020 1% en Guadeloupe 3% en Guyane et
à la Réunion quand il concerne 20% des
assurés au niveau national
l'accélération du passage à 43 annuités
de cotisations viendra renforcer la
difficulté pour les habitants de ladite
outre-mer dans les années 60 à atteindre
le nombre de trimestres requis pour
bénéficier d'une pension complète cela
les contradra donc à travailler jusqu'à
67 ans l'âge du taux plein l'article 40
de la Constitution ne nous permet pas de
sortir les collectivités d'outre-mer de
l'application de ce nouveau calendrier à
défaut cet amendement demande un rapport
au gouvernement sur les conséquences de
l'accélération de l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation dans les outre-mer
merci chers collègues et maintenant nous
avons à nous prononcer enfin nous avons
examiné une série de sous amendements
qui commencent par le et vous venez
d'assister un nouveau rebondissement
dans l'examen de cette réforme des
retraites au Sénat le président du
groupe les républicains Bruno Retailleau
devait défendre ce matin un amendement
qui accélère la suppression des régimes
spéciaux de retraite de certains régimes
spéciaux de retraite qui est prévu par
ce gouvernement et finalement et bien
cet amendement a été reporté plus tard
dans le texte de cette réforme de
retraite on va retrouver Steve Jourdain
qui a suivi ses échanges tendus ce matin
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat Steve
racontez-nous un peu ce nouveau
rebondissement oui c'est ce qui
s'appelle démarrer pied au plancher Alex
vous l'avez dit on était censé reprendre
l'examen de cette réforme des retraites
avec cet amendement de Bruno Roteo qui
prévoit effectivement d'accélérer la
suppression des régimes spéciaux elle
est plus vite en quelque sorte que ce
que veut le gouvernement finalement la
Commission des social a demandé à ce que
cet amendement soit examiné plus tard
c'est-à-dire après l'article très ce
qu'on comprend aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle et bien c'est que on assiste
on reprend sur un tempo de guérilla
parlementaire avec une droite qui veut
aller très vite qui veut que cette
réforme soit examinée d'ici à dimanche
minuit c'est la deadline qui est fixée
par le gouvernement et une gauche qui va
tenter bien de ralentir les débats Voir
d'empêcher et bien à ce que cette
réforme à ce que ce projet de loi soit
voté dans l'ensemble donc ce dimanche il
reste quelques jours d'examen et ça
promet on le voit aujourd'hui d'être
encore très mouvementée Alex merci
beaucoup Steve avant de réagir à ce
nouveau rebondissement avec le sénateur
socialiste Rémi Cardon va faire un
nouveau détour par la séance de
l'hémicycle du Sénat pour voir ce qu'il
passe ce qu'il se passe
d'accord on n'avait pas le même devant
nous comme quoi vous voyez nous non plus
nous n'avons pas toujours les mêmes
éléments
bon mais en réalité monsieur le
Président canner les masques sont tombés
vous faites de l'obstruction ce rapport
c'est sous amendements c'est
effectivement quand même de
l'obstruction
donc
je consulte le gouvernement sur cet
amendement 608
défavorable explication de vote monsieur
geumier et ensuite de Madame meunier
monsieur Chaumier c'est à vous
à le ministre a été tellement
synthétique que je l'ai pas entendu
excusez-moi
c'est à Madame amendement qui est
important puisque il porte effectivement
sur la question de nos collègues des
départements ultramarins qui présente
comme c'est exposé expliqué dans
l'exposé des motifs je fais pas le
relire mais des caractéristiques de
carrière qui sont bien différentes et
d'état de santé aussi qui sont bien
différents et d'indicateurs d'espérance
de vie en bonne santé qui sont également
très différents et pas dans un sens
favorable donc cette question n'a pas
été traitée n'est pas traitée en fait
dans ce projet de loi ça a été soulevé
par Victorin Lurel de façon très forte
hier ou avant-hier dans le débat la non
prise en compte de ces particularités
dans ce projet de loi et donc la demande
de ce rapport sur les conséquences de
l'application des dispositions prévues
nous paraît tout à fait importante je
pense que c'est un message qu'on va
porter envers nos compatriotes de ces
départements ultramarins que nous ne
sommes pas en train de porter une loi
qui une fois de plus va porter atteinte
à l'égalité sociale entre les résidents
des départements d'outre-mer et ce de
métropoles c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous estimons que ce rapport nous savons
qu'elle est attitude générale du Sénat
sur cette question mais ce rapport est
particulièrement important je vous
remercie
s'il n'y a pas d'autres demandes
d'explication de l'autre je vais donc
mettre vous à cet amendement 608 avec
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement quelles sont ceux qui sont
pour
contre
abstention n'est pas adoptée nous
passons une série d'amendements en
discussion communes nous commençons par
deux amendements identiques le premier
et le 223 présenté par Monsieur
chanterelle qui a la parole
merci monsieur le Président retour dans
la salle des conférences du Palais du
Luxembourg siège du Sénat pendant
l'examen de cette réforme des retraites
avec un nouveau rebondissement ce matin
pour en parler j'accueil sur ce plateau
Rémy Cardon bonjour vous êtes sénateur
socialiste de la somme alors pour
expliquer ce qui s'est passé le
président du groupe les républicains
Bruno Retailleau devait présenter ce
matin un amendement en amendement
important dans le débat puisqu'il
accélère la suppression de certains
régimes spéciaux de retraite qui est
prévu par cette réforme des retraites et
finalement la droite sénatoriale a
décidé de reporter le débat sur cet
amendement à plus tard dans l'examen de
cette réforme qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Rémi Cardon la droite sanatoriale
refuse de débattre elle refuse de
débattre puis surtout elle a tendance à
changer les règles du jeu à chaque fois
c'est ce qu'on remarque et puis en plus
de ça moi j'appelle ça en fait de
l'obstruction en réalité parce que vous
décalez ça vous voulez faire ça tout
simplement la réalité c'est le faire le
débat dans la nuit c'est qu'ils ont peur
d'assumer devant les Français ce qui va
faire c'est accélérer la suppression des
régimes spéciaux dans le temps parce que
c'est un amendement de ce type en
réalité ce qu'on remarque c'est que
Monsieur Retailleau cherche toujours à
changer les règles du jeu donc ça
s'appelle de l'obstruction et en plus de
ça il va il va aller plus loin que le
gouvernement dans ce dans la dans cette
réforme des retraites alors on voit la
complicité entre le gouvernement qui
active le 47-1 et Monsieur Retailleau
qui active soit l'article 38 soit le 44
pour maintenant changer les l'ordre des
des articles du passage des article bon
voilà on voit clairement moi j'invite à
me suivre retailleux de revenir dans le
débat de fond de se calmer parce que
l'argument c'est on nous coupe
l'électricité dans des permanences et du
coup on décale le débat enfin qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire enfin moi je ne
comprends pas
climat social qui est tendu dans cette
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites avec effectivement des actions
qui sont menées par certains opposants
des coupures d'électricité qui peuvent
toucher des personnes malades qui ont
besoin de respirateur également
de santé ce lien qui a été fait dans le
débat entre et bien la volonté de la
gauche équatoriale de débattre et ce qui
se passe dans tout le pays vous le
comprenez ce lien qui a été fait en fait
pour alors malheureusement l'article 7 a
été voté hier soir mais il y a urgence
peut retirer c'est très fort en fait
qu'on voulait généralement un bon deal
un compromis en tout cas la culture du
compromis que Monsieur du stop tu as pu
avoir à une certaine époque qui avait
chez les socialiste c'est que
normalement personne n'est personne est
content tout le monde a fait un pas vers
l'autre là on attend que le gouvernement
et la majorité sanatorielle fasse un pas
vers les Français c'est tout simplement
c'est ce qu'on attend alors sur ce
report de l'amendement de Bruno
Retailleau l'un des arguments qui est
aussi évoqué par la Commission des
averses sociales c'est qu'elle n'a pas
eu encore vraiment le temps d'examiner
les centaines et les centaines de sous
amendements c'est-à-dire des amendements
qui modifient l'amendement de Retailleau
des sous amendements qui ont été déposés
par la gauche alors certains diront que
c'est un peu pour ralentir les débats la
gauche notariale et encore dans une
stratégie de rallonger les débats Voir
d'options alors ce que je remarque c'est
que la droite c'est latérale change de
change de méthode à chaque fois un coup
c'est on a on a pas eu le temps de de
regarder les sous amendements un autre
coup bah sous un moment tu as pas
forcément regarder mais ils sont ils
recevable un autre coup c'est bon
figurez-vous on va vous activer 38 pour
aller très vite sur ses amendements on
voit la fin en fait on sent on sent la
panique en fait cette droite on sent la
panique merci beaucoup Rémi Cardon
d'être venu sur le plateau de Public
Sénat on va tout de suite rejoindre
l'hémicycle du Sénat ou les sénateurs
continuent à examiner les articles
additionnels après le fameux article 7
de cette réforme des retraites il faut
quand même le signaler en repoussant le
débat et ça montre que vous voulez pas
le débat
ce que ce que je veux vous dire aussi à
travers ses amendements les Français
établis en France vous allez prendre et
vous avez souvent pris des situations à
l'international en disant regardez
là-bas c'est 65 ans c'est 67 ans et vous
ne connaissez pas vraiment le sujet nous
on le connaît parce que la plupart de
nos compatriotes vivent dans ces pays
donc on peut très bien vous rapporter
des témoignages des conséquences
justement de ces réformes dans ces pays
et je peux vous dire que la plupart du
temps les pays que vous prenez
d'ailleurs vous prenez pas tout parce
qu'il y a des pays aussi des endroits où
c'est à 60 ans par exemple c'est le cas
dans celui dans lequel j'ai vécu dans la
province du Québec où c'est à 60 ans
après il y a un système différent bien
évidemment mais c'est quand même à
partir de 60 ans donc il faut regarder
les choses dans l'entièreté et les pays
justement qui poussent plus tard c'est
de la pauvreté souvent je peux vous dire
c'est les taux de pauvreté pratiquement
les plus importants c'est ça que vous
voulez vendre à notre société
c'est-à-dire d'avoir des personnes âgées
pauvres c'est pas ça en tout cas que
nous nous souhaitons défendre et le
l'intérêt d'avoir de ce recul que nous
avons ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
que nous ne faisons pas de l'obstruction
l'obstruction de ce banc là c'est pour
ça que nous avons mis ces amendements
pour que nos compatriotes établir de
France puissent également apparaître
dans ce débat parce que c'est important
également qu'ils apparaissent dans ce
débat mais bien évidemment nous
retirerons les autres sous amendements
monsieur le Président c'est entendu et
dans la discussion commune nous avons
encore le 2017 présenté par Madame
Conway Mouret qui a la parole
merci
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
en effet la réforme que vous proposez un
pacte négatif bon sur la vie de 68
millions de Français dont les 3 millions
que vous avez oublié comme vient de le
rappeler mon collègue Yann chanterelle
dans ce texte ceux qui ont choisi de
vivre à l'étranger alors ils l'ont bien
compris et notamment la moitié de la
population qui représente les femmes et
qui vous font savoir en manifestant
massivement qu'ils n'en veulent pas
manifestation d'ailleurs qui ont eu lieu
également à l'étranger notamment à
Berlin et à Madrid pourtant vous entêtez
alors que l'examen du texte a mis en
lumière les grands oubliés de votre
réforme celles et ceux qui ont des
carrières hachées c'est malheureusement
le cas de tous nos compatriotes qui font
le choix de la mobilité et qui vivent à
l'étranger pendant une période plus ou
moins longue certains ont travaillé en
France c'est parfois dans plusieurs
autres pays et selon l'Observatoire de
l'expatriation 39% des séjours à
l'étranger sont motivés par une
opportunité professionnelle et pas moins
de 25% pour des raisons sentiment alors
elles sont nombreuses car ce sont
majoritairement des femmes même si nous
avons un nombre croissant d'hommes à
renoncer à exercer une activité
professionnelle afin de suivre leur
conjoint au poste à l'étranger et mettre
fin parfois une carrière prometteuse il
est pas toujours facile de retrouver du
travail en France au retour ni à
l'étranger pendant l'expatriation c'est
donc bien la grande majorité de celles
et ceux qui sont souvent nos meilleurs
ambassadeurs et ambassadrices à
l'étranger qui sont directement
concernés par votre réforme c'est
pourquoi nous demandons au gouvernement
de remettre au Parlement un rapport
examinant les conséquences économiques
et sociales du relèvement de l'âge de la
retraite à 64 ans pour les Français
établir de France
et enfin le dernier amendement dans ces
discussions communes n'est pas défendue
donc nous avons trois amendements sur
lesquels il nous avons besoin de la
ville de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur 223 2017 et
effectivement chers
c'est tout à fait important de prendre
de
s'intéresser
aux assurés établis hors de France ainsi
que leur conjoints et de voir un peu
comment sont pris ces interruptions
professionnelles se posent également le
cas de des femmes françaises qui
accouchent dans un pays étranger en
suivant leur conjoint et puis qui quand
elle rentre n'ont pas également
les trimestres par exemple de majoration
prise en compte où elles ont un blanc
dans leur carrière donc c'est un sujet
très intéressant mais qui a déjà été
largement largement étudi é notamment
par le corps et vous monsieur
chanterelle qui semblait si j'ai bien
compris tout savoir puisque les autres
ne savaient rien c'est ce que vous nous
avez dit
c'est ce que vous nous avez dit
mille excuses mais monsieur chanterelle
on discutera juste en aparté par exemple
sur les différences entre le régime
Suisse et le régime en Ouzbékistan qui
nous permettra je pense d'être très
constructif dans le débat donc il y aura
un rapport défavorable mais peut-être
que Monsieur le Ministre peut donner des
précisions par rapport à ce sujet
d'importance
monsieur le ministre sur ces trois
amendements la vie du gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président comme vous
le savez comme mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le savent de manière très
générale il y a toujours des exceptions
mais de manière générale le gouvernement
s'oppose aux demandes de rapport
considérant que pour bien des sujets les
les compétences du Parlement en matière
de mission d'information de commission
d'enquête d'évaluation du contrôle du
gouvernement sont là pour permettre la
remise et la production de rapport
souvent un rythme et avec une forme
d'objectivité plus importante que
lorsqu'il s'agit de le confier au
gouvernement sous l'autorité des
différents ministres qui dirigent les
services donc la vie est favorable ceci
étant dit j'ai eu l'occasion de répondre
à Monsieur fraça ainsi qu'à madame
garou-mella il y a quelques jours sur la
question des Français d'étrangers pour
dire que un rapport ne suffirait pas à
régler les difficultés rencontrées par
nos ressortissants à l'étranger qu'il y
a des difficultés conventionnelles que
chaque situation renvoie à une nécessité
d'une convention d'un accord fiscal et
social parfois les deux avec les pays
concernés tant pour les questions de
transfert de droit les questions de
versement de pension des questions de
fiscalisation ou non de ces pensions
ainsi que sur la difficulté que monsieur
fraça avait pointé vous avez pointé
monsieur chanterelle concernant le choix
du pays l'impossibilité de faire une
valeur des droits dans des pays
différents je me suis engagé au tout
début de ces débats parce qu'un groupe
de travail transpartisans avec les
parlementaires sénateurs et députés des
Français étrangers puissent avancer sur
ces sujets là et j'ai précisé que ça
sera un travail de fourmi et titanesque
dans le même temps puisqu'il faudra en
réalité examiner la situation de chaque
pays faire en sorte de pouvoir avancer
ou d'espérer dans une relation
bilatérale qui nécessite un accord
partagé je le rappelle de sur chacun des
sujets et ensuite avoir des projets de
loi ou des propositions permettant les
ratifications des conventions donc ça
n'est que le début d'un long processus
mais processus auquel je me suis engagé
[Musique]
républicains sur l'amendement 223 qui a
fait l'objet de deux avis défavorable
il n'y a pas de demande d'explication de
vote avant ce vote
monsieur le Président comptable
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai
bien entendu les explications de
Monsieur le de Monsieur ministre mais
c'est vrai que on voit que c'est un
sujet c'est un sujet important et que
justement pour le coup l'exception sur
un sur une demande de rapport environ à
2,5 millions de Françaises et de
Français vivent à l'étranger ça a été
rappelé et pour autant pas un mot de
leur situation dans la réforme des
retraites du gouvernement c'est
évidemment un oubli de taille car il
sont trop souvent pénalisés par
disposition existantes et subirer de
plein fouet les conséquences de
certaines mesures prévues par ce projet
de loi ils sont pénalisés parce que les
Françaises et Français l'étranger ont
souvent des carrières morcelées
notamment parce que il est ont tendance
à changer de poste plus fréquemment les
quatre personnes ayant à travailler dans
plusieurs et dans différents pays ne
sont pas rares de tels parcours
professionnel sont de plus en plus
fréquents d'un côté de plus en plus de
français et de français par travailler à
l'étranger de l'autre côté les
entreprises ont de moins en moins
recours aux détachement mais font signer
davantage de contrat de travail locaux
donc on voit bien en fait par rapport à
l'ensemble de ces arguments et par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit Monsieur
le Ministre j'entends le le la
proposition en tout cas qui a un groupe
de travail et que et qu'on a on sera
attentif en tout cas à la création de ce
groupe à ce groupe de travail mais c'est
vrai que je pense que là il me semblait
plutôt nécessaire en tout cas qu'on
inscrive le fait qu'un rapport soit
demandé et qui puisse nous éclairer sur
cette situation
avant le vote sur le 223
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'entends votre votre argument
et je sais que les rapports sont pas ne
sont pas populaires et généralement
rejeté cependant la demande d'un rapport
permet d'abord d'avoir un calendrier
puisque le rapport doit être remis et
même si en effet un groupe de travail et
bien évidemment si les parlementaires
sont conviés à le rejoindre et bien nous
serons de cela
comment
permettrait quand même de pouvoir
avancer sur ce sujet je ne pense pas
qu'il faille revoir l'ensemble des
conventions fiscales elle peut bien sûr
bien sûr être étudiée mais le rapport
permet de rassembler l'ensemble de ces
argumentaires et surtout d'avancer dans
un calendrier qui sera donné parce que
comme vous l'avez mentionné c'est un
travail de fourmi mais cela veut dire
que il va prendre des années et que
finalement nous ne serons pas assez
rapidement l'impact que c'est très forme
aura sur les Français vivant à
l'étranger ou plus particulièrement pour
ceux qui veulent partir à l'étranger et
qui ont besoin d'avoir une information
complète quant à ce qui les attend quand
ils rentreront en France un jour
parlait ensuite à me conseiller le
compte puis à Monsieur chanterelle
oui monsieur le Président moi je
soutiendrai vraiment très fermement
cette demande de rapport d'autant que
j'ai posé une question écrite au mandat
précédent sur effectivement la
problématique des retraites pour nos
compatriotes qui sont à l'étranger je
n'ai pas eu de réponse
ma question est devenue obsolète
je l'ai reposée je tiens à dire que je
l'ai reposé et donc si ce rapport était
voté je retirerais ma question écrite ce
qui permettra au gouvernement d'avoir de
meilleurs taux statistiques de réponse
aux questions écrites des parlementaires
compte
3 oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre des chers collègues
compte tenu des des spécificités
finalement des personnes qui font une
partie de leur carrière à
l'international ça n'est pas simplement
le sujet des Français à l'étranger c'est
d'une manière générale les personnes qui
font une partie de leur carrière
internationale la manière dont ils
n'auront pas de décote parce qu'ils ont
fait des années à l'étranger la manière
dont on va compter leurs années en
France alors que la moitié ici la moitié
de leur carrière est fait à
l'international et ben les 25 meilleures
années c'est toutes leurs années de
carrière pour je pense aussi en
particulier au fonctionnaires qui sont
détachés et qui travaillent en
particulier dans nos écoles françaises à
l'étranger en recrutement local je pense
aussi aux personnes qui travaillent en
recrutement local dans nos services
diplomatiques et consulaires et qui
n'ont pas accès parfois à la retraite
française sur tous ces sujets monsieur
le ministre les dispositions pourraient
être législatives mais elles sont
d'abord réglementaires ça relève aussi
de la manière dont on interprète
l'application des conventions fiscales
et donc un rapport pose la position du
gouvernement à son intérêt donc bien
entendu il convient de voter ses
amendements mais quoi qu'il arrive des
travaux pour faire pour permettre de
faire évoluer la réglementation sur les
sujets qui nous tiennent à cœur en
particulier l'absence de décote l'accès
à la capacité de cotiser à la retraite
lorsqu'on travaille pour les services
français à l'étranger en recrutement
local ce sont des sujets qui méritent
effectivement que nous échangeons tous
ensemble le plus rapidement dans un
groupe de travail parce que si vous
posez maintenant la condition de d'âge
pour liquider la retraite à 64 ans pour
un certain nombre de Français qui
vivaient à l'étranger dans des pays où
la retraite est à 60 ans ça pose aussi
une difficulté et il y aura pendant
quelques années un certain nombre de
personnes qui auront besoin d'aller au
consulat demander les allocations de
solidarité ce qui est aussi une
difficulté monsieur chanterelle et
ensuite madame Vogel oui monsieur le le
Président nous avons bien pris note
monsieur le ministre votre ouverture et
la création de un groupe transpartisan
évidemment nous y participerons pour
pouvoir améliorer la situation de nos
compatriotes établis hors de France et
permettre ses avancées mais je voudrais
répondre aussi à Monsieur Savary puisque
je ne peux pas rester sans réponse vous
dites vous savez tout mais vous savez je
suis quand même un des représentants de
non compatriotes établi hors de France à
travers vos propos vous les insultez
aussi moi je vous donne pas de leçon sur
la situation dans la Marne donc je vous
demanderai un peu de respect puisque
c'est ce que nous faisons nous pouvons
d'ailleurs et c'est tout à l'honneur de
notre hémicycle débattre des fois c'est
durement sur le fond mais je pense qu'il
y a un respect minimal qui devrait être
de séances entre nous et de ne pas se
livrer à ce genre à ce genre d'attaque
puisque vous passez beaucoup de temps à
parler du fait de vouloir débattre sur
le fond donc faites-le appliquez-le à
vous-même et continuons nos débats
intervenez d'ailleurs c'est toujours
très intéressant quand vous intervenez
sur le fond pour que nous puissions
continuer sereinement nos débats sur le
fond et d'étudier tous les amendements
que nous avons déposés merci à vous
madame Vogel explique son vote
madame bogel c'est à vous pour expliquer
votre vote oui merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président donc la raison pour
laquelle nous avons déposé ces
amendements ça a été très bien expliqué
par mes collègues c'est que
nous sommes dans une situation où les
Françaises et les Français qui sont
établis hors de France ont souvent eu
une partie de leur carrière en France
une partie de leur carrière à l'étranger
parfois dans différents pays parfois ils
reviennent en France parfois pas et ils
sont un peu et elles sont un peu dans la
situation au fond des femmes en France
qui ont des carrières hachées sauf que
dans beaucoup de circonstances ces
Françaises et des Français n'ont même
pas eu des carrières hachées c'est
simplement que la manière dont on
calcule leur salaire annuel moyen la
manière dont on liquide la retraite et
discriminatoire puisque on ne tient pas
compte des années effectuées à
l'étranger donc on est dans une
situation où le fait d'avoir
étudié ailleurs travailler ailleurs qui
participent de la richesse du monde de
la richesse de nos sociétés ces Français
français qui apporte tellement à
l'étranger mais qui est aussi rapporte
tellement en France au fond son
pénalisés pour avoir une carrière pas
uniquement en France et donc la seule
chose qu'on vous qu'on vous demande
c'est simplement de faire un rapport
pour étudier la manière dont cette
réforme en particulier qui comme elle va
affecter en particulier toutes les
personnes en France qui ont des
carrières hachées puisque ça deviendra
plus difficile d'atteindre les 64 ans va
aussi en particulier affecter beaucoup
les Françaises et les Français de
l'étranger il et elles sont dans des
situations très variables il y a
beaucoup de situations des pays où il y
a des conventions des pays où il y en a
pas autant de situations que de français
et de français néanmoins je crois qu'on
a vraiment besoin d'avoir une
objectivation de des conséquences sur
leurs droits c'est la raison pour
laquelle on vous demande un rapport il y
a 3 millions de personnes qui va à
l'étranger je pense que c'est pas
beaucoup demandé que simplement de
savoir quel va un impact sur leur vie
sur leur droite de cette réforme je vous
remercie donc nous avons deux
amendements en discute identiques sur
lesquels nous allons prononcer nous
avons d'ailleurs deux demandes de
scrutin public sur ces deux amendements
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions de l'article 56
le scrutin est ouvert
oral du gouvernement et de la Commission
le Sénat continue son examen de la
réforme des retraites que vous suivez en
direct sur Public Sénat et sénateurs
votent actuellement sur un amendement
qui demande un rapport sur les
conséquences de cette réforme des
retraites pour les français établi hors
de France l'expatriation qui entraîne
parfois des carrières hachées avec des
conjoints qui sont obligés de suivre
leur conjoint à l'étranger et cela a
forcément des impacts sur leur carrière
et donc au final sur leur pension de
retraite ce sont des amendements venus
de la gauche qui demandent la
publication et de ce rapport sur les
conséquences de cette réforme des
retraites les sénateurs votent
actuellement par scrutin public sur leur
tablette électronique des scrutes un
public qui sont demandés assez souvent
par la gauche notamment pour rallonger
les débats
344 exprimé 343 pour les amendements 93
contre 250 ils ne sont donc pas adoptés
et sur le troisième amendement
discussion communes 2017 de Madame
Conway Mouret nous avons également une
demande de scrutin
qui va être annoncé
et il va être procédé dans les
conditions de l'article 56 avec double
avis défavorable le scrutin est ouvert
les sénateurs qui continuent à voter sur
un nouvel amendement qui demande un
rapport pour établir les conséquences de
cette réforme de retraite sur les
Français établis hors de France a noté
que dans la nuit hier la majorité de
droite et du centre du Sénat à voter le
fameux article 7 de cette réforme des
retraites qui reporte l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans après deux journées de
soirée et de nuit de débat intense
autour de cet article 7
les résultats sont les suivants votants
344 exprimer 343 pour 93 contre 250 il
n'est pas adopté
nous en venons à l'amendement
2392 qui est présentée par Monsieur Joly
et ses collègues sur le Président
cheministre mes chers collègues vous le
savez comme moi la l'évolution
démographique de la France va conduire à
la croissance dans les prochaines années
continuent de la part des personnes
âgées ce vieillissement était au gène
sur le territoire national on fait en
définitive on constate des parts de
population
âgées plus importantes dans les eaux
urbaines que dans les zones dans les
zones rurales plus que dans les zones
urbaines avec des écarts vraiment très
sensibles puisque une part de la
population en Île-de-France des
personnes de plus de 60 ans qui est de
11 de 15,5% et avec des maximales qui
sont dans Limousin pour le prendre
exemple d'une région après 30% et
au-delà de 30% pour ce concerne le
département de la Creuse outre les
écarts entre les régions les retraités
semblent donc en proportion je le disais
plus nombreuses sur les territoires
ruraux c'est un nous devons donc au
gouvernement de remettre un rapport au
Parlement examinant les conséquences
économiques et sociales du relèvement de
l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans pour les
Français vivant dans les zones rurales
au regard de ce que de ceux qui vivent
dans les zones urbaines l'enjeu est une
compréhension des spécificités du
vieillissement milieu rural et de leur
principe organisateurs c'est un enjeu
qui tient essentiel pour un rapport
essentiel pour appréhender l'aménagement
des territoires le développement des
services médicaux sociaux en direction
des populations RG l'accompagnement
social des parcours de vie dans la
vieillesse et permettre le développement
d'une action publique adéquate et
pertinente en effet les territoires
ruraux sont ne sont pas tous également
préparés face aux vieillissement voire à
la géronto croissance et qui les
concerne et les politiques locales
prennent diverses
solutions qui le convient d'examiner
d'analyser de diagnostiquer pour pouvoir
les adapter voilà le sens de cette
amendement
c'est une des conséquences particulières
de cette loi est article 7 qui a été
évoquée sur les territoires ruraux de la
même manière qu'on a évoqué à l'occasion
d'autres débats les conséquences liées
aux catégories aux typologies aux
natures d'emplois différentes dans les
territoires européens par rapport au
territoire urbain je vous remercie
quelle est la vie de la Commission
merci c'est une demande de rapport donc
avis défavorable sachant que ce sujet
ont déjà étudié dans nombre était
étudiés dans nombre d'articles de presse
ou à travers les organismes qui
planchent sur les problèmes de retraite
je mets aux voix cet amendement 23,92
avec double avis des favorable qui est
favorable
qui est contre cet amendement
abstention il est pas adopté toujours
après l'article 7 nous avons
l'amendement 3161
présenté par Madame pensé manger ses
collègues elle a la parole
merci monsieur le Président à
l'argenticipe qu'on puisse me reprocher
que ce n'est pas dans cette loi qu'il
fallait mettre mon amendement mais dans
la loi immigration parce qu'en fin de
compte si vous voulez toutes ces études
ont un point commun c'est qu'elle montre
l'insuffisance de l'étude d'impact faut
dire que il a pas été il a pas été fait
par le Conseil d'État et donc tous ces
rapports effectivement
demande des rapports sur des points
particuliers de l'impact de cette loi
c'est aussi simple que ça et c'est ça le
lien alors selon une étude de l'INSEE si
les immigrés représentent moins de 10%
de la population française il représente
par contre 20 % des personnes pauvres
et je vous rappelle que 62 ans 25% des
personnes les plus pauvres et bien sûr
pas toutes les pauvres sont déjà
décédées parmi ces derniers les les
personnes immigrées sont très sur
représentées une part des travailleurs
immigrés ont des carrières hachées donc
on rejoint l'amendement précédent
notamment en raison de discrimination à
l'embauche on sait que c'est un des
facteurs de discrimination les plus
forts
ils sont souvent après au chômage
8,5% en moyenne contre 4,7% pour les non
immigrés et
ils sont aussi entrés souvent
tardivement sur le marché du travail
français de plus et je tiens le
souligner dans leur relevé de carrière
il manque effectivement souvent de
nombreux années non déclarées par les
employeurs et ils payent de façon
massive le prix fort de pratique
illégale d'employeurs exploitateur peu
scrupule donc du fait de carrière à
faible salaire incomplète beaucoup de
travailleurs immigrés vivent avec l'ESPA
s'il y en droit sur représenté dans les
métiers et les secteurs j'en ai parlé
hier les ouvriers les employés qui vont
payer le prix le plus fort
de cette réforme les travailleurs
étrangers donc pâtiront d'autant de
façon
proportionnellement plus forte du recul
de l'âge de la retraite voilà l'objet de
cet amende la vue de la Commission sur
l'amendement 3161 madame le rapporteur
général oui chers collègues la vie est
toujours des favorable et c'est vrai que
on aurait pu demander je sais pas moi
1000 rapports sur tel catégorie sur
telle statut sur
telle conséquence de cette réforme sur
sur
les retraités mais en réalité vous avez
aussi eu une étude d'impact vous l'avez
certainement vu chers collègues parce
que je sais combien vous êtes attentive
à repérer tous les éléments de réflexion
il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup et de la
part de la CNAV et de la part du
ministère un certain nombre d'éléments
qui ont été donnés et je pense que on
est tous renseignés après qu'il y ait
effectivement des catégories ou des
personnes qui sont en situation
difficile je ne le nie pas et c'est
d'ailleurs pour une personne en
particulier que nous nous sommes engagés
pour la plupart d'entre nous c'est pour
défendre ces réalités difficiles
cependant demander des rapports c'est
sans doute très contradictoire avec
votre volonté d'avoir des réponses à vos
questions écrites aussi parce qu'on peut
pas demander au ministère de lancer des
lancer des rapports des rapports et des
rapports et demander aussi des questions
écrites des questions écrites et des
questions écrites je crois qu'il faut
être raisonnable en tout et si on doit
retrouver la sérénité il faut retrouver
le raisonnable dans nos demandes c'est
un avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre votre avis
et pas bien entendu c'est défavorable
monsieur le ministre c'était bien
défavorable
j'ai une demande de scrutin public
demandée par le groupe écologiste sur
cet amendement 3161
le scrutin
va être annoncé
conformément l'article 56 le scrutin est
ouvert
les sénateurs qui continuent à débattre
de cette réforme des retraites avec
actuellement un scrutin public sur des
amendements qui portent sur les articles
additionnels après l'article 7 on le
rappelle la nuit dernière le Sénat a
voté en faveur de cet article 7 qui
reporte l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans
les sénateurs sont en train d'examiner
les derniers amendements après cet
article 7 et après bien le Sénat devrait
passer à l'article 8 et on en parlera
dans quelques instants
344 exprimé 343 pour le moment de 93
contre 250 il n'est pas adopté et il
nous reste le 3186 également présenté
par Madame ponce qui a la parole
oui merci monsieur le président
une étude du Centre du Centre d'études
de l'emploi et du travail la réforme de
2010 c'est intéressant à sensiblement
augmenter le nombre d'arrêts maladies de
longue durée chez les seniors pour un
surco estimer 68 millions d'euros cette
étude laisse à penser qu'un nouveau
report et il sera plus grave je suppose
qu'à nouveau rapport de l'âge la
vulnérabilité augmentant avec l'âge
et la moindre résistance des seniors à
l'intensité du travail
auprès aux pressions temporelles va y
compris aux accidents professionnels va
aller croissants et que ça risque ça
risque ça va se traduire par des
surcoûts pour l'assurance maladie et la
TNT sans que cela ne soit vraiment
analysé et d'ailleurs y compris dans les
tableaux d'équilibre par ailleurs de
nombreuses études concluent à un effet
négatif de l'allongement de la vie
active sur la santé qu'elle soit
objectivement décrite c'est à dire par
des études scientifiques ou
auto-évaluées et l'augmentation de la
prévalence des taux de dépression et des
troubles mentaux par le travail n'est
pas un phénomène anodin puisqu'il serait
à l'origine de 20% des arrêts de travail
à cet âge un chiffre en constante
augmentation depuis 2016 nous notons
donc que vous ne prenez pas suffisamment
contre les effets de la réforme
sur le système de santé
et l'augmentation des arrêts maladie
l'augmentation prolongée par exemple de
l'exposition aux agents chimiques
provoquant des maladies
ultérieurement à la période de travail
et enfin les répercussions de ce report
de l'âge sur la santé perçue et objectif
comme le montre un certain nombre
d'études et tout cela du fait des
inégalités de santé oui j'ai parlé de
deux enfermes parce qu'à ces âges
l'impact sur la santé ces deux ans ferme
de la Commission sur un rendement 3186
madame le rapporteur je pense que vous
avez madame
pensez Monge il y a du lien entre
l'assurance maladie et la branche
vieillesse et il y a du lien entre la
branche vieillesse et puis la branche
autonomie tout ça c'est on est d'accord
et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui constitue la
sécurité sociale c'est pour cette raison
que moi j'ai pas été choqué que ce soit
porté cette réforme des retraites par ce
PLFSS et donc
vous demandez un rapport une nouvelle
fois mais je crois que nous avons chaque
année l'opportunité de regarder
précisément le rapport qu'il y a entre
ces différentes branches et
je vous laisse à penser que c'est ce
qu'on fera à la prochaine saison de
discussion sur la sécurité sociale
c'est vrai que plus on avance en âge et
puis on peut avoir des difficultés je
pense que chacun peut rendre compte on
vieillit on prend de l'âge et il y a des
difficultés qui arrivent mais pour
autant est-ce que on doit parler de de
cette difficulté là maintenant alors que
il y a encore en attente beaucoup de
sujets beaucoup de sujets qui sont
importants notamment
les bornes d'âge la pénibilité justement
qui fera du lien aussi avec votre sujet
moi je pense que là vous essayez de
gagner du temps et c'est très pénible
c'est un avis
défavorablement mais ma vie que la
Commission madame ponce pour expliquer
votre vote
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai
oublié de répondre à Madame la
rapporteur sur mes questions écrites non
là vraiment il n'y a pas d'inflation
c'est pas comme l'inflation des prix
j'ai posé depuis 2020 où je suis
sénatrice 15 questions écrites 8 ont eu
une réponse j'attends les 7 routes je
pense que c'est tout à fait sobre et je
suis assez pour la sobriété de ce point
de vue
favorable à cet amendement numéro 3186
après double avis défavorable qui est
pour
qui est contre
abstention il n'est pas adopté nous
emmenons à l'article 8 sur lequel madame
ponce est inscrite puis plusieurs autres
orateurs madame poncement c'est à vous
sur l'article 8
et pour ceux qui nous rejoignent sur
Public Sénat le Sénat va commencer
l'examen de l'article 8 de la réforme
des retraites qui concernent les
carrières longues après l'adoption hier
soir de l'article 7 sur le report de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 64
ans alors début des débats aujourd'hui
sur l'article 8 qui concerne précisément
les départs anticipés et notamment les
carrières longues car et bien vous le
savez malgré le report de l'âge à 64 ans
le gouvernement a quand même conservé un
dispositif de départ anticipé pour ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt avec
plusieurs seuils ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 16 ans pourront partir
à 58 ans s'ils ont tout leur trimestre
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler entre
16 et 18 ans pourront commencer pour
partir à 60 ans et puis pour ceux entre
18 et 20 ans ils pourront partir à 62
ans ces carrières longues ça a été
l'objet d'un débat ou le à l'Assemblée
nationale et de tractations entre les
républicains et le gouvernement avec
notamment le député
qui a mis la pression sur le
gouvernement pour faire des concessions
sur ce dispositif carrière longue
Elizabeth borne a d'ailleurs annoncé des
concessions durant le débat l'Assemblée
nationale les travailleurs qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 20 et 21 ans
pourront partir à 63 ans et ce qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 16 et 17 ans
pourront partir à 60 ans voilà
maintenant le débat sur les carrières
longues qui n'a pas eu lieu à
l'Assemblée nationale va avoir lieu au
Sénat et je vous le propose de le suivre
en direct avec des amendements de
suppression qui sont défendus par la
gauche
et va même renforcer la précarisation
des sites des personnes en situation de
handicap je sais que vous n'avez pas
bougé l'âge mais justement la quête
trouve que vous auriez dû le bouger dans
un sens de le réduire il aura pareil en
effet contestable de présenter certaines
mesures de statu quo ou de faible
avancée tels que le maintien de la
retraite anticipée pour une aptitude à
62 ans ou pour handicap à 55 ans comme
du progrès c'est ce que je vous disais
hier quand vous n'aggravez pas vous vous
c'est un progrès et bien la caisse
effectivement dit que vous n'êtes pas au
rendez-vous selon le collectif handicap
le report de l'âge légal à 64 ans va
pénaliser les personnes en situation de
handicap qui elles ne peuvent pas
bénéficier des dispositifs dérogatoires
à sa à 60 à 55 ans pardon mais qui
rencontre de grandes difficultés pour se
maintenir en emploi
et donc elle passe en moyenne elle 8 et
demi sans emploi
merci ensuite madame Benbassa
merci monsieur le président
vous nous présenter cette réforme comme
un projet porteur de justice sociale et
de progrès nous ne sommes pas dupe de
votre hypocrisie vous faites passer pour
une avancée sociale le simple maintien
de la retraite anticipée à 70 ans pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
nous devrions donc nous satisfaire de
cela
quand on sait qu'à l'origine ces
personnes connaissent des difficultés
dans le monde du travail en raison de
leur limitation qu'elle rencontre aussi
des soucis dans leur scolarité que
l'environnement
urbain est inadapté à leur mode de vie
on ne peut que déplorer une fois de plus
que le gouvernement n'intègre pas
davantage les situations les citoyens en
situation de handicap dans sa politique
de réforme sociale
pourtant
19% des Français en situation de
handicap vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté contre 13% de la population
générale d'après un rapport de ligase en
date du 16 décembre 2022 les retraités
déclarés inap vivent en moyen 4 à 6 ans
de moins que les autres traités si je
résume les personnes en situation de
handicap trouve difficilement du travail
sont plus précaires que le reste de la
population qui les exclut vivent moins
longtemps et dans de moins bonnes
conditions quoi qu'il arrive des
travailleurs handicapés sont perdants et
vous échouez à leur garantir une vie
digne et une retraite digne votre texte
souligne particulièrement sur ce point
un manque d'ambition client comme tous
les restes de votre politique la
solidarité l'inclusion l'intégration
sont des mots slogans que vous ne
comptez jamais mettre en pratique merci
ensuite
de groupe puisque c'est notre règle
monsieur joignandais pour les
républicains cet article 8 est très
important pour notre groupe des
Républicains puisque c'est à cette
occasion que nous voulons vraiment faire
une avancée importante pour les femmes
et notamment pour les pour les maires de
famille
je voudrais interroger
occasion de cet article 8 le ministre
monsieur le ministre s'il vous plaît
j'aurais vraiment besoin avec les
quelques vins sénateurs qui ont signé
mon amendement sur la question des 43
ans d'explication précise les carrières
longues à certains nombres d'entre nous
n'y comprennent rien
nous avons déposé un amendement pour
simplifier les choses ok pour les 64 ans
j'ai voté nous avons voté les 64 ans il
est la question des 43 ans pour
équilibrer les choses nous souhaiterions
que c'est 43 ans soit une limite maximum
de cotisations on a 43 ans on s'en va
alors si on dit ça et si on amende comme
ça monsieur le ministre combien ça
touche de personnes en plus par rapport
au texte que vous nous proposez et
combien ça coûte parce qu'en tant que
responsable ici on amende il faut qu'on
sache qu'on vient ça coûte sauf qu'on a
des chiffres dans tous les sens aussi
bien de la commission que du
gouvernement on ne sait pas combien donc
s'il vous plaît combien de personnes
concernées pour cet amendement et
combien ça coûte enfin je voudrais dire
à nos collègues de gauche cet amendement
nous l'avons retiré pourquoi nous
l'avons retiré parce qu'on va pas
prendre le risque que vous nous posiez
dessus 500 amendements au dernier moment
mais bien sûr donc donc vous êtes en
train de nous de vous êtes en train
d'empêcher un débat démocratique vous
empêchez un débat démocratique sur un
sujet qui nous intéresse tous vous nous
empêchez d'amander et vous nous faites
une belle séance de simulation c'est
c'est comme sur les terrains de football
l'avant-centre l'avant centre monsieur
can ner vous êtes occupé un peu de sport
au gouvernement c'est l'avant centre qui
se couche dans les 18 mètres pour avoir
un penalty ça s'appelle de la simulation
et bien quand l'arbitre quand l'arbitre
quand l'arbitre ne s'en aperçoit pas
quand l'arbitre ne s'en aperçoit pas et
bien siffle la penalty mais quand il
s'en aperçoit il donne un investissement
et je souhaite
que nos concitoyens ouvrent les yeux je
ne peux pas amender en raison de
obstruction merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre nous avons encore
deux collègues inscrits pour parler sur
l'article et donc je propose que si vous
voulez ajouter des observations vous le
fassiez après
vous préférez le faire avant la fin des
orateurs et bien les yeux monsieur le
président
j'entends dans mon oreille derrière moi
il y a pas de penalty quand on est hors
jeu je trouve que c'est une belle
expression
mes chers collègues
continuons à travailler avec un peu de
sang-froid
[Musique]
je je vous le dis très tranquillement
vous ne pouvez pas
reprocher à votre position de faire
simplement son travail de position alors
que en étant majoritaire vous disposez
d'outils de ce règlement intérieur qui
ont été d'ailleurs débloquer hier en
conférence des présidents et je pense à
l'article 42 10 en particulier qui vient
se rajouter à l'article 38 que vous
utilisez manière sporadique plus le 42
16 etc le déplacement d'amendement
revient sur l'amendement de Monsieur
Retailleau donc écoutez on peut à chaque
fois vous faire un rappel au règlement
pour nous dire pour vous dire respecter
votre position simplement comme nous
nous vous respectons et nous gagnerons
du temps pour pouvoir permettre le débat
merci monsieur le Président nous
poursuivons donc les prises de parole
une par groupe suivant l'accord passé en
conférence des présidents sur l'article
8 il nous reste madame meunier madame
apource poli et maintenant monsieur
Canevet pour le groupe centriste madame
meunier
le président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues nous vous le disons depuis
presque une semaine maintenant cette
réforme financière et ce reportage légal
à 64 ans comporte des conséquences
sociales graves les rustines que vous
nous proposez à l'article 8
ne sont à l'heure et ne tromperont pas
les millions de Françaises et de
français mobilisés contre cette réforme
ainsi que leur représentants là je veux
relayer les inquiétudes importantes du
secteur du handicap alors que cet
article prétend atténuer les injustices
et bien cet article risque au contraire
d'aggraver les inégalités d'accès au
départ anticipé pour les personnes en
situation de handicap et en situation
d'incapacité les travailleurs les plus
vulnérables sont pénalisés je parle là
des titulaires d'une pension
d'invalidité les personnes inapte au
travail les allocataires de la location
adulte handicapée les travailleurs
handicapés les travailleurs en
incapacité permanente à la suite d'un
accident de travail ou d'une maladie
professionnelle je parle aussi des
fonctionnaires handicapés et vous dites
assouplir les conditions d'accès à la
retraite anticipée des travailleurs en
abaissant le taux d'incapacité
nécessaire à 50% et en remplaçant la
condition des trimestres validés par
celles des trimestres cotisés cette
durée de cotisation reste encore trop
longue pour les personnes en carrière
hachées et à la fatigabilité élevée la
substitution des trimestres validés par
les trimestres cotisés aura pour effet
de compliquer l'accès au dispositif nous
ne regrettons que ici la majorité
sénatoriale est déclarée ircevable de
nombreux amendements allant dans ce sens
pour corriger le tir la fixation de
l'âge de départ anticipé va aggraver
cette situation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
collectivement nous nous plongeons dans
la lecture de l'article 8 le débat
interne des républicains sur
l'adaptation des règles de départ
anticipées pour les carrières longues
conduisent-ils les droites à accepter
cette fois-ci à des bas beaucoup plus
large avec nous présenter comme la
caution sociale de cette réforme cet
article
prolonge en réalité
un statu quo injuste pour les
bénéficiaires du dispositif carrière
longue vos diversions ne trompent
personne à terme vous déclarez d'un an
l'âge de départ à la retraite pour
celles et ceux ayant commencé à
travailler à 18 ans après avoir mené la
guerre au régime pionnier vous vous
apprêtez à maintenir les seuls régimes
spéciaux injustes oui en imposant une
durée de cotisation majorée d'un an
porté à 44 annuités vous réservez un
traitement spécial à celle et ce ayant
commencé à 14 16 et 18 ans le vent tout
de suite le doute ce je vais vous
présenter comme des droits nouveaux
constituants en réalité des reculs des
grands reculs
sociaux c'est recul concernent très peu
de personnes si en 2004 126
000 carrières longues partaient à la
retraite avant 60 ans ils étaient
seulement
238 en 2021 votre réforme n'y changera
rien vous décidez de reconduire ces
mesures uniquement parce qu'elles
s'inscrivent dans une dynamique
d'extinction du dispositif carrière
longue selon une projection de la CNAV
le nombre de bénéficiaires des retraites
anticipées pour carrière longue sera
divisée par deux dans 20 ans les
carrières hachées des femmes et des
jeunes y contribuent en pleinement la
droite au Sénat aura-t-elle le courage
de protéger les carrières longues en
supprimant les mesures d'âge pour les
travailleurs ayant commencé à cotiser
avant 21 ans il reste monsieur Canevet
comme erreur de groupe mais j'ai une
demande de une demande de règlement de
rappel règlement mais le président rénal
accepte de le faire après donc monsieur
Canevet vous avez la parole merci
le groupe de l'Union centriste et bien
sûr satisfait que l'on puisse enfin
parler de vrais sujets c'est-à-dire des
sujets de cessation
progressive de l'activité ou anticipé de
l'activité d'usure professionnelle de
l'ensemble des mécanismes de solidarité
mais je vous rends attentif mes chers
que lors d'un failli ne pas y arriver
puisque le vrai débat sur ce texte c'est
quand même ça et
l'exemple de ce que l'on voit là c'est à
dire la succession de d'amendements du
même groupe pour exactement le même
objet supprimer le supprimer l'article
voilà n'a aucun sens ça veut dire que ça
prive notre capacité de débattre de
réels sujets de préoccupation de
l'ensemble des Français parce que le
temps va expliciter de façon redondante
ces amendements ce seront ce sera autant
de temps de moins que nous aurons nous
collègues du groupe de l'Union centriste
pour pouvoir exprimer véritablement
notre vision de la société
notre vision du sujet des retraites et
cela on l'observe depuis le début de la
semaine et depuis le week-end dernier et
on espère qu'enfin les oppositions
seront de compte qu'il faut que l'on
débattre du fond et non pas qu'on
utilise des artifices de procédures qui
empêche qui empêche réellement le débat
du fond donc j'espère que ils vont se
ressaisir qu'enfin on va pouvoir
s'exprimer
le président rénal à la parole pour un
rappel au règlement
sur la base de l'article 33 du règlement
et sur la prise de parole donc mettons
en cause de Monsieur Joan des et puis
d'ailleurs je prendrai en même temps
monsieur camper dans la réponse si on
permettait
non je voudrais dire de des choses assez
simples le premier point
relève de
l'argumentation monsieur jeandais en
disant on a dû retirer notamment
mais la cause principale chers collègues
du retrait de votre amendement c'est le
fait qu'il y a aujourd'hui et je le dis
sans eux un accord entre la majorité
sénatoriale et le gouvernement et non
mais c'est un accord qui fait que
certains abandonnements sont acceptés
préalablement et d'autres ne le sont pas
le vôtre ne l'a pas été par vos amis
aujourd'hui ne portez pas la
responsabilité sur nous je vous en prie
deuxième point et d'ailleurs il est
repris par Monsieur il est repris par
Monsieur canvé vous dites on ouvre là
une séquence de je sais pas combien
d'amendements de suspension
identique oui mais je vous rappelle
l'article 40 monsieur Canevet la
différence qu'il y a entre vous et nous
c'est que vous à juste titre je conteste
pas vous avez négocié avec le
gouvernement et donc tout ce qui devait
passer et mais finalement est couvert
par le gouverte et couvert par le
gouvernement par l'intention
gouvernement et vous permet de déposer
des articles ici non seraient article 40
et comme nous on n'a pas cette
possibilité et bien on est obligé de le
faire à travers un abandon suppression
ce que vous savez monsieur cadet par
cœur vous le savez parfaitement et donc
là vous jouez un jeu dangereux qui est
de et oui et donc c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça que la l'idée monsieur Kennedy
qui est derrière votre popo d'ouvrir
encore une fois de 38 c'est une
fumisterie parce que on est obligé de
passer par ces amendements là et qui
vont lever nous qui vont nous permettre
de faire nos propres propositions je
vous remercie je crois que le Sénat a
parfaitement compris votre
votre rappel au règlement est maintenant
monsieur joyeux en œuvre en faire un
autre et ensuite la commission
s'exprimera puis le gouvernement le
président sur le même article du
règlement parce que j'ai été mis en
cause ce que vous dites est faux je m'en
chers collègue pourquoi cet amendement
était retiré ce matin parce qu'à la
lumière de l'expérience d'hier soir vous
avez mis 500 sous amendements sur
l'amendement de notre collection triste
qui a été obligé de retirer son
amendement donc il y a aucun problème
pour discuter il y a aucun problème pour
discuter de cet amendement ici au fond
et j'aurais bien été d'ailleurs
satisfait qu'on puisse en parler
ensemble de ce sujet des 43 ans
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai pas eu le temps
de dire tout à l'heure au ministre c'est
que j'attends des réponses très précises
sur ce sujet d'ailleurs j'ai voté les 64
ans pour moi la compensation ce sont les
43 ans de cotisations et j'attends les
réponses précises du ministre qui
conditionneront mon vote final sur
l'ensemble du texte de loi je le dis
parce que je pense que c'est une c'est
une question importante donc mon chers
collègues mon cher collègue il y a pas
tous des jeux que de que vous que vous
que vous imaginez je pense que vous êtes
dans un moment difficile vous commencez
à retirer vos sous amendements parce que
c'est de plus en plus difficile pour
vous de supporter et d'expliquer votre
stratégie parce que vous vous jouez sur
une chose vous vous espérez vous espérez
que nos concitoyens ne vont pas
comprendre vous les prenez pour des
oiseaux en essayant en essayant en
essayant en essayant de leur faire
croire que c'est nous qui faisons
d'obstruction en essayant de mais ils
commencent à s'en rendre compte il
commence à s'en rendre compte et c'est
pour ça que vous retirez vos sous
amendements parce que ça devient
insupportable ne prenez pas les français
pour des oiseaux et respecter
l'institution la grande institution du
Sénat j'ai été élu Benjamin de cette
maison en 95 mes chers amis oui et ben
je n'ai jamais je n'ai jamais vu je n'ai
jamais vu je n'ai jamais vu une
opposition se comporter comme ça c'est
absolument détestable
alors
madame Brulin souhaite également faire
un rappel au règlement et ensuite la
Commission va s'exprimer madame Brulin
merci
[Musique]
pour le même article et je voudrais
féliciter notre collègue qui vient bien
de parler de ce que c'était une carrière
longue notamment sur ses bancs il faut
il faut mettre un peu du mou et de
détente dans notre débat j'espère que
vous l'aurez considéré comme ça je
voudrais rassurer je voudrais rassurer
nos collègues chaque amélioration qui
sera apportée
sur quelle que soit le bande où il d'où
elles viennent nous les voterons et si
d'aventure nous devions sous amender des
amendements ce serait pour améliorer
encore les améliorations que vous-même
proposez vous aurez l'occasion de le
voir dans l'examen de cet article le
problème c'est effectivement que si vous
avez retiré votre amendement mon cher
collègue c'est le fruit d'un accord avec
le gouvernement parce que ce
gouvernement préfère négocier avec une
poignée de républicains qu'avec une
inter syndicale unie et solide
je pense que ce n'est pour aucune autre
raison que vous avez retiré votre
amendement et vous ne ferez croire à
personne ici que vous l'avez retiré pour
empêcher nos sous-amendements ou alors
vous vous déclarez à tout le monde que
vous renoncez à améliorer la situation
des Français parce que vous ne le pouvez
pas ici je voudrais terminer en disant
que
plus d'une cinquantaine de nos collègues
de droite et du centre ont refusé hier
de voter l'article 7 il s'en est ajouté
trois ce matin je voudrais féliciter ses
collègues qui ont fait cela qui en fait
cela malgré sans doute de nombreuses
pressions dont ils ont été l'objet
et et vous dire que les fissures et les
lézardes qui commencent
[Musique]
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur merci
merci
revenons un petit peu au fond du
problème un peu de sérénité dans les
débats je voulais vous exprimer ici
simplement
la philosophie de
adopté par votre commission des affaires
sociales en ce qui concerne l'ensemble
des dispositifs de ce texte voyez-vous
vous l'avez vu au niveau par exemple de
l'article 2 on a essayé de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse prendre en compte
davantage l'employabilité des seniors
par rapport à ce qui nous était proposé
et que cette réforme s'applique à tout
le monde c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons fait des propositions à la
fois par exemple pour les sonnets
orchidées au chômage des propositions
pour ceux qui étaient en emploi vous
voyez c'était construit autour de cette
volonté que l'on puisse faire répartir
cette effort collectif sur le plus de
personnes non pas pour les pénaliser
mais pour faire en sorte que
sur davantage il ne soit pas concentré
ces efforts sur certains dans le domaine
de la pénibilité vous le verrez à
l'article 9 nous pensons également qu'il
faut prendre des dispositions
différentes et vous verrez que à travers
les âges anticipés on prend en compte la
pénibilité pour ceux qui sont exposés
dans les risques différemment ce qui
concerne l'inaptitude qu'elle a aussi un
autre facteur mais différent
indépendants du monde du travail ou en
ce qui concerne l'invalidité et il nous
appartient à ce moment-là de prendre des
dispositions pour des retraites
anticipées mais ce que je voudrais bien
que l'on partage c'est que quand on
prend une disposition pour un agent
anticipé de retraite ça veut dire que
nous accordons
aux personnes concernées une retraite
plus longue que les autres on sait que
la durée moyenne des retraites c'est
aller on va dire 20 ans 22 ans voilà 20
ans
c'est derrière cette durée un rapport
par rapport à votre
sûr au travail c'est la raison pour
laquelle notre objectif a toujours été
d'être attentif à ce que cette durée
plus longue accordée parce que on peut
penser derrière qui a des vies et
notamment des espérances de vie qui ne
sont plus courtes c'est pour ça que le
dispositif doit être non pas le plus
juste possible on y arrivera pas mais le
moins injuste possible
en ce qui concerne les maires de famille
on va l'aborder là aussi la même
stratégie nous pensons que dans un
dispositif ou un demande à tout le monde
de travailler plus faut prendre en
compte les difficultés des maires de
famille et faire en sorte qu'on arrive à
améliorer leur pension c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons plutôt choisi
ce dispositif de surcotte qu'un âge
d'ouverture avancée des droits et dans
tout cela la logique de la commission
essaiera de s'appliquer à un maximum de
personnes c'est d'ailleurs la même
logique
me semble-t-il que nous aurons ce qui
concerne les régimes spéciaux pour faire
en sorte que ceux qui ont une usure
professionnelle qu'il soit dans un
régime spécial ou à côté puissent
bénéficier effectivement s'ils ont une
espérance de vie moins d'une durée plus
longue d'une durée plus longue de la
retraite mais pour des raisons de prise
en compte de la pénibilité pas pour des
raisons historiques voyez-vous c'est un
raisonnement du XXe siècle par rapport
au raisonnement du 19e siècle qui
faisait que on accordait une retraite
par anticipée c'est un droit social en
compensation d'un salaire moindre et
bien non mais non on réfléchit plus
comme ça et les Français doivent être
assurés que nous soyons le moins
inégalitaire possible dans les
différents dispositifs de cette réforme
et c'est la raison pour laquelle me
semblait important de les rappeler en ce
qui concerne cet article 8 merci alors
avant que nous passions la discussion
des amendements monsieur le ministre
vous souhaitiez vous exprimer pour
répondre à Monsieur canevin à Monsieur
jeandais autant pour moi merci monsieur
le Président si vous me le permettez je
répondrai même peut-être à d'autres
sénateurs qui sont exprimés simplement
pour d'abord commencer par deux points
qui sont de volonté de ma part
d'apporter et pardon pour les auteurs
des corrections à des propos madame
pensez-moi je vous avais ouvert cette
discussion générale sur l'article en
disant que parmi les départs d'anticipés
la pénibilité donc l'incapacité était le
facteur principal ça n'est pas vrai ça
n'est pas vrai nous avons 42% des
assurés qui chaque année partent avant
l'âge légal général si vous motorisez
cette expression sur ces 42% 22 partent
au titre des départs pour carrière
longue les départs anticipées pour
carrière longue 15 pour des questions
relatives à l'incapacité l'invalidité ce
sont cent mille personnes par an cela
renvoie comme la dimension rapporteur à
l'article 9 parce que j'ai eu l'occasion
je crois de le partager avec vous soit
au début de nos travaux sur la maison
des débats en commission mais je ne
trouve pas satisfaisant à la fois
humainement intellectuellement je ne
trouve pas satisfaisant qu'un assuré sur
15 peut-être un peu moins
partent pardonnez-moi un assuré sur 7
parte de manière anticipée pour des
problèmes de santé je pense que l'enjeu
que nous avons et d'avancer sur les
questions de prévention de la pénibilité
parce qu'il y a 1000 fois plus de
satisfaction et 1000 fois plus d'intérêt
à permettre par la prévention un maximum
d'assurer d'aller jusqu'à l'âge légal
quoi qu'on pense de cet âge plutôt qu'à
compenser des difficultés de santé par
un départ anticipé de deux ans je
préfère que les assurés partent au bon
âge en bonne forme plutôt que de manière
anticipée en mauvaise santé et c'est
tout l'enjeu de la prévention vous avez
dit madame la sénatrice que ce
dispositif avait vocation à s'étendre et
c'est vrai que si nous ne faisons rien
si nous restons sur le dispositif de
carrière longue j'y reviendrai pour
répondre à Monsieur jeu Yandé
si nous ne faisons rien ce dispositif à
vocation à effectivement concerné de
moins en moins de monde pour une raison
toute simple c'est que l'âge moyen
d'entrer dans la vie active tant
augmenter donc mécaniquement le nombre
de personnes ayant cotisé des trimestres
suffisamment tôt pour bénéficier d'un
dispositif carrière longue invocation
ABC mais ce que nous proposerons pas au
Sénat et donc au Parlement d'adopter
avec notamment une nouvelle borne d'âge
vient contrecarrer ce mouvement ensuite
il y a une deuxième inexactitude que je
voulais à laquelle je voulais apporter
une correction qui a été exprimée
notamment par Madame Benbassa mais je ne
sais pas si elle est restée avec nous et
qui a été reprise pour une partie par
madame la sénatrice meunier c'est ce qui
concerne la situation du handicap nous
maintenons il n'y a pas de dégradation
c'est le premier point que je souligne
nous maintenant à 55 ans la possibilité
d'un départ anticipé pour les
travailleurs handicapés
et donc il n'y a pas de dégradation de
cette borne d'âge c'est un maintien pur
et dur et ensuite madame meunier vous
avez évoqué le fait que les critères
pourraient être plus restrictifs c'est
justement l'inverse que nous faisons
actuellement dans le cas d'un assuré qui
est né en 1972 et qui souhaitent partir
à 55 ans il faut remplir une double une
double condition avoir cotisé 118
trimestres et en avoir validé 20 de plus
60 38 nous gardons la cotisation la
durée de cotisation à 118 aujourd'hui
ces deux conditions sont cumulatives
demain la durée de cotisation est 118
sera exclusive ce qui permettra des
assurés en cotisait 118 trimestres de ne
pas avoir à se poser la question des
vins trimestres supplémentaires de
validation à obtenir pour pouvoir partir
et donc c'est une facilitation du départ
pour les travailleurs en situation de
handicap de la même manière d'ailleurs
que dans le cas des départs en
incapacité quoi qu'on pense de ses
départs et quoi que j'ai dit sur
l'utilité de la prévention
nous prévoyons dans le texte que nous
vous proposons que les travailleurs qui
ont un taux d'inaptitude un taux
d'incapacité supérieure à 20% puisse
bénéficier d'un départ anticipé comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui de manière
automatique et non pas sur avis médical
considérant que dès lors que le taux
d'incapacité supérieur à 20% on peut
considérer que la vie médicale adore
déjà été rendu et avec une ampleur une
importance suffisamment significative
pour autoriser un départ anticipé sans
passer par un deuxième avis médical j'en
viens à
deux points sur lesquels je conclurai
pardon c'est un peu long mais cela me
permettra d'aller beaucoup plus vite sur
les très nombreux amendements et
sous-amendement de l'article d'abord le
dispositif de carrière longue monsieur
c'est un juillandé m'a interpellé mais
je crois que c'est un sujet qui concerne
et qui intéresse beaucoup de sénateurs
comme il est intéressé beaucoup de
députés quel est le dispositif
aujourd'hui il a été créé en 2003 il
autorise des travailleurs des assurés
plus exactement qui ont rempli trois
conditions à partir de manière anticipée
il y a un jamais dispositif pour ceux
qui ont cotisé en fonction de leur date
de naissance petite complexité
supplémentaire entre 4 et 5 trimestres
par an mais restons sur 5 pour faciliter
la démonstration cinq trimestres avant
16 ans c'est un départ anticipé autorisé
à partir de 58 ans et 5 trimestres
autorisé 2 ans avant l'âge légal donc
aujourd'hui 60 demain 62 mais il y a
trois conditions cumulatives et
impératives la première c'est d'avoir
cinq trimestres cotisés avant la borne
d'âge tels que définie par la loi la
deuxième c'est d'avoir atteint l'âge
d'ouverture des droits spécifiques fixés
en relation avec chacune des bornes
d'âge et la troisième c'est d'avoir une
durée de cotisation
requise qui soit intégralement cotisée
sans tenir compte des trimestres
validées et j'ajoute aussi que dans
l'état du droit
pour le dispositif moins de saison il
s'agit d'une durée de cotisation égale à
la durée de cotisation exigée pour tous
les assurés plus 8 trimestre soit deux
ans donc en l'occurrence 44 ans et
demain 45 ans chose que nous allons
modifier et abaisser pour celles et ceux
qui ont cinq trimestres avant 20 ans
c'est le même système c'est d'avoir cinq
trimestres avant 20 ans d'avoir atteint
aujourd'hui les 62 ans demain les 62 et
d'avoir 42 de main 43 années
intégralement cotisé c'est un point qui
est très important le caractère cotisé
parce que c'est ça qui est la cause des
plus grandes déceptions pour les assurer
puisque aujourd'hui si vous faites
valoir le droit à un départ anticipé
parce que vous avez atteint les 60 ans
et que vous avez cotisé 5 trimestres
avant 20 ans il va falloir démontrer que
vous avez cotisé 168 trimestres et il se
peut que vous ayez fait un service
militaire qui vous est droit à 4
trimestres valider mais non cotisés il
ne compte pas une femme qui commence à
travailler avant 20 ans qui a un moment
de sa vie
prend bénéficie c'est logique c'est un
droit d'un congé parental ce sont les
trimestres validés qui ne comptent pas
dans la durée cotisée nous allons
changer aussi si je prends ces deux
exemples c'est pour souligner que en
l'état du droit et je vais venir sur ce
que nous proposons de changer ainsi que
sur les coûts vous allez demander en
l'état du droit le dispositif de départ
anticipé pour ceux qui ont travaillé
avant 20 ans qui se traduit dans la loi
par une bonification de deux ans la
bonification effective constatée pour
qu'on tienne compte des trois critères
cumulatifs c'est 9 mois
c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est une
machine à déception c'est parce que
quand on affiche dans la loi un
dispositif de départ anticipé à deux ans
les conditions cumulatives que j'ai
exposées font que l'on vient à 9 mois je
viens à votre question
je le dis parce que c'est comme ça que
le système était construit et ça
détermine les réponses que j'apporte sur
des questions de couple vous avez évoqué
que proposons-nous avec cette loi nous
proposons deux choses d'abord la
première c'est de créer une nouvelle
borne d'âge à 18 ans pour faire en sorte
que ceux qui ont cinq trimestres avant
18 ans puissent bénéficier non pas de
deux ans des parents anticipées mais de
4 ans et nous allons vous proposer nous
allons soutenir plutôt nous l'avons
proposé à l'Assemblée nous allons
soutenir ici un amendement permettant de
créer une borne d'âge avec une
bonification d'un nom pour ceux qui ont
5 trimestres avant 21 ans on peut
convenir que quand on arrive à 21 ans on
peut s'interroger sur le fait d'avoir
commencé très jeune ou moins jeune
c'est ce que nous vous proposons vous
m'avez posé des questions sur le coup
des amendements que vous avez retiré
pour les raisons que vous avez évoquées
il y a plusieurs coûts que je peux
partager avec vous s'il s'agit de dire
comme ça a été évoqué à l'Assemblée
nationale à la fin des débats le
vendredi s'il s'agit de dire que les
deux conditions cumulatives que j'ai les
trois conditions cumulatives que j'ai
évoquées serait modifié pour dire que le
départ serait autorisé dès lors que
l'âge spécifique d'ouverture des droits
les cinq trimestres cotisés sont
remplies mais qui n'est pas exigé
d'avoir plus de 43 années au moment de
l'atteinte de l'âge spécifique
d'ouverture des droits ça coûte 300 à
350 millions d'euros s'il s'agit de dire
que tout assuré qui a commencé à
travailler un jour avant ses 21 ans ne
se voit pas appliquer
un âge d'ouverture des droits mais
simplement une durée de cotisation à 43
ans cela coûte entre 7 et 10 milliards
d'euros c'est vous en conviendrez une
abordable et s'il s'agit de dire que
tout assuré qui a commencé à travailler
avant 21 ans se voit absolument garantie
indépendamment de toute tâche spécifique
d'ouverture des droits et uniquement par
le maintien de la condition du nombre de
trimestres avant tel ou tel âge de
départ cela coûte 1 milliard 7
ce sont des chiffres qui sont
conséquents qui sont extrêmement
importants et qui viennent contredire
l'objectif d'équilibre que nous pouvons
les uns et les autres partager nous
avons cette difficulté là je souligne
parce que nous avons cet objectif
d'équilibre du système je termine d'un
mot sur les carrières longues avant de
dire un mot de l'amendement monsieur
Savary
un mot sur les carrières longues puisque
vous avez évoqué monsieur le sénateur
l'idée que finalement nous pourrions
garantir que les 43 années de cotisation
serait une forme de plafond et et que ça
sera un plafond auquel au-delà duquel on
ne demandera à personne d'aller je ne
peux qu'être en opposition avec cette
proposition car la philosophie même je
ne sais pas si le terme est le plus
approprié mais en tout cas les principes
même de construction de notre système de
retraite depuis qu'il existe sont de
cumuler deux conditions pour le départ
l'âge d'ouverture des droits et je le
répète nous l'avons évoqué à l'article 7
le fait d'avoir un âge légal d'ouverture
des droits et une protection contre les
machines à des cotes que sont les
systèmes fondés uniquement sur la durée
de cotisation et une durée de cotisation
sauf que la durée de cotisation dans le
système tel qu'il est pensé n'a toujours
a toujours été vu comme un plancher
jamais comme un plafond je prends deux
exemples pour illustrer premier exemple
il est extrêmement simple d'une certaine
manière
c'est que chaque année sur les 800 000
départs à la retraite nous avons 180 000
assurés qui partent avec plus de
trimestres qui n'en faut c'est un fait
constaté parce que justement c'est un
plancher et nous avons évoqué à
l'article 7 nous avons même adopté vous
avez adopté pardon un certain nombre
d'amendements concernant les enseignants
du primaire qui démontrent qui était
facile de passer le nombre de trimestres
requis et le deuxième exemple c'est pour
partager avec vous les progrès qui ont
été faits depuis une vingtaine d'années
avant 2003 avant la création des
dispositifs de carrière longue l'âge de
départ était à 60 ans et la durée de
cotisation requise à 37 ans et demi si
vous faisiez des études vous aviez une
licence une maîtrise peu importe et que
vous commenciez votre carrière à 22 ans
et demi vous travaillez 37 ans et demi
vous prenez votre retraite à 60 ans à
taux plein et votre camarade de classe
de primaire ou de collège ou de primaire
plutôt vous pouvez commencer à
travailler dans une usine à 15 ans et
devoir travailler 45 ans pour avoir une
retraite à taux plein au même âge que
vous à 60 ans ça faisait un écart de 8
ans et parfois plus pour ceux qui
commencent à travailler très tôt
avec les carrières longues cet écart
c'est progressivement réduit et
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un système
qui fait que pour ce qui est la durée de
cotisation requise et à la fois pour
atteindre ce plancher et pour atteindre
les âges d'ouverture des droits les
quarts et de 1 2 ans et avec ce que nous
vous proposons notamment sur les
carrières longues avant 18 ans et les
carrières longues avant 21 ans ça sera
un an et même moins d'un an en fonction
de votre date de naissance et du moment
auquel vous rentrez dans la vie active
vous avez aussi évoqué cela a été dit
par Madame pour ce poli je crois que en
fonction de l'âge auquel on commence on
pourrait être amené à travailler 43 ou
44 ans la réalité est plus complexe ce
raisonnement et celui que vous avez eu
madame la sénatrice n'est juste que dans
le cas où les assurés commencent à
travailler le jour de leur anniversaire
on peut commencer à travailler à 16 ans
mais bien souvent c'est 16 ans et 3 mois
bien souvent c'est 16 ans et demi et
dans ce cas-là ce n'est pas 44 ans qui
sont réalisés pour atteindre l'âge
d'ouverture des droits c'est 43 ans et 3
mois 43 ans et 6 mois 43 ans et 9 mois
et donc évidemment dire qu'il y aurait
un plafond au-delà duquel on n'irait pas
ça n'existe pas parce qu'on ne peut pas
construire une société dans laquelle on
garantit à tous les individus de ne pas
travailler un jour de plus que les
autres ça ne marche tout simplement pas
avec notre système de protection sociale
je termine par un dernier point monsieur
le Président pour dire un mot de
l'amendement de Monsieur Savary adopté
par la commission des affaires sociales
et dont nous avons beaucoup discuté avec
les uns et les autres j'ai eu l'occasion
de dire que je reconnaissais là
l'initiative du président rotaïeu
c'est un point qui est important parce
que ça concerne la question des des
femmes des mères mais en réalité ce qui
concerne la question des droits
familiaux que propose cet amendement et
qui nous paraît dans le bon sens il
propose de tenir compte du fait que
progressivement l'augmentation de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits et ça n'est pas
lié à ce sel à cette seule réforme c'est
un mouvement beaucoup plus long cette
augmentation de l'ouverture des droits
c'est se traduit peut se traduire pardon
par le sentiment ou la constatation
qu'il est trimestres à quiothique de la
maternité ou d'éducation des enfants
deviennent moins utiles
en fait c'est un mouvement de société
que nous connaissons la carrière des
femmes le taux d'emploi des femmes
progressent et c'est une très bonne
nouvelle et de ce que les droits
familiaux ont été créés lorsque les
trimestre de maternité ont été créés
dans les années 60 et 70 ils étaient
pensés pour compenser des trimestres
pendant lesquels les femmes ne pouvaient
tout simplement pas cotiser parce que le
congé maternité n'était pas suffisamment
élevé pour
transformer le trimestre entre mes
cotisée et parce qu'il y avait une
interruption d'activité aujourd'hui
c'est une bonne nouvelle plus souvent il
y a toujours évidemment plein de
difficultés mais plus souvent une femme
qui accouche peut valider le trimestre
par le congé maternité et reprendre son
activité pour valider de trimestres et
c'est trimestre de compensation
deviennent des trimestres de majoration
et cet endroit qui est comme cela qui
existe et on ne le remet pas en cause
par contre qu'une femme qui a une
carrière complète ou quasiment complète
un an près qui arrive à l'âge
d'ouverture des droits peut si elle a
travaillé 42 ans sans interruption
particulière peut considérer que ces
trimestres sont ainsi perdus ou en tout
cas moins utile la réalité c'est que la
situation varie beaucoup selon les
femmes les femmes sont toujours plus
exposées que les hommes aux carrière
hachées et donc pour beaucoup d'entre
elles le fait d'avoir des trimestres de
majoration évite d'avoir des décote
parce que ça permet d'avoir les 42 ou
les 43 ans requis et puis pour d'autres
c'est moins utile l'amendement qui est
proposé qui a été adopté par la
commission des affaires sociales elle le
mérite de conserver les deux intérêts on
maintient les majorations de droits les
majoration de durée d'affiliation pour
les femmes pour les parents puisque je
rappelle qu'il y a des trimestes
d'éducation qui peuvent être réparties
entre les parents au sein du couple
donc nous maintenons ces droits là pour
celle le plus souvent qui ont une
carrière incomplète cela permet d'éviter
la décote ou de la limiter ce qui est
une très bonne chose et pour celle le
plus souvent mais parfois ce mais c'est
très très majoritairement celle qui est
arrivé un an avant l'âge d'ouverture des
droits à 63 ans ont une durée
d'affiliation requise atteinte par ces
trimestre de majoration alors qu'il leur
reste un an à travailler le système de
surcote permet d'apporter une
compensation et la compensation paraît
juste pour une seule raison pour une
raison particulière c'est que si une
femme a pu travailler toute sa carrière
et faire une carrière complète malgré le
fait d'avoir des enfants c'est la
démonstration que sa maternité ces
maternité n'ont pas été inconciliables
avec sa carrière professionnelle par
contre ce que l'on sait
c'est que si cette conciliation est plus
facile ou moins difficile aujourd'hui la
maternité reste un frein à la promotion
et si c'est un frein à la promotion sans
être un empêchement de travailler le
fait de majorer la pension et peut-être
la plus juste décompensations à apporter
au moment de la retraite et c'est
adoption monsieur le Président vous avez
raison c'est la parentalité d'une
certaine manière pour être plus large
que la seule maternité ou la seule
paternité et donc ça permet de conserver
ces deux aspects c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement sera favorable
à cet amendement
alors la présidente de la Commission a
demandé la parole pour le débat sur les
amendements
la Commission propose au Sénat de
disjointe l'amendement
2127 du rapporteur des rapporteurs de la
discussion commune et en application de
l'article 44 à 6 de règlement la
Commission demande la priorité des amas
de vote sur cet amendement
donc sur la priorité
le gouvernement ne s'y oppose pas
comme
pour les décisions la commission prise
précédemment le Gouvernement s'en remet
la commission
alors la priorité est ordonnée
et alors en vertu de la clique 46 bis
alinéa 2 du règlement
la Commission demande l'examen séparé de
l'amendement de 1127 de la commission
avant l'article 8 enfin au début de la
discussion des articles 8 est-ce qu'il y
a un orateur qui s'y oppose
madame Rossignol madame la Présidente
rossignol
je ne répondrai pas la question est-ce
qu'il y en orateur qui s'oppose je
voudrais juste parce que quand même ça
demande qu'on serait adapte même si on
est très souple et très flexible
est-ce que vous allez encore nous sortir
l'article 38 dans 30 secondes ou est-ce
que sur cette terre et sur cette
amendement qui est important où on peut
en vraiment en bonne intelligence
considérée qu'il y aura des choses à
dire pour beaucoup d'entre nous est-ce
qu'on peut cesser le temps du débat au
moins ça abonnement et tous ceux qui me
connaissent et qui savent qu'elles sont
mes sujets peuvent comprendre que ma
question est absolument sincère
oui madame la Présidente pour expliquer
votre proposition
bon écoutez je veux bien qu'on discute
ainsi mais bon faut quand même pas
passer moins une expression un peu
populaire nous prendre pour des lapins
de 6 semaines
on prend pour des lapins de 6 semaines
vous vous poussez des cris d'or frais
parce que en effet
l'adoption de l'amendement ferait tomber
les amendements de suppression mais vous
allez déposer 300 sous amendements ce
qui fait qu'on va discuter jusqu'à ce
soir cette nuit de l'article de
l'amendement de l'A
de l'amendement non attendez regardez
les sous amendements regardez les sous
amendements
300 c'est pas votre question mais c'est
ma réponse 300
300 sous amendements 300 sous
amendements dont nous allez discuter
tout l'après-midi le début de la soirée
haute alors me dites pas qu'on vous
prive de discussion sur l'amendement de
surcote des femmes de René Paul Savary
parce que là un moment bon je viens tout
entendre mais ça va
alors
[Applaudissements]
nous devons nous prononcer sur cette
demande de prior d'examen séparés
monsieur le Président Kanner
monsieur le Président je crois que vous
accepterez quand même que la décision
emportée par Madame de roche
modifie considérablement lors de
lancement de nos travaux ben oui ben
c'est comme ça
venez pas nous reprocher des sites
parler alors que vous vous êtes en train
de nous empêcher de parler donc monsieur
le Président je sollicite de votre
bienveillance pour nous permettre de
nous réorganiser une suspension de
séance de 10 minutes
madame la Présidente considérez-vous que
c'est utile pour le déroulement des
travaux
vous avez 300 sous amendements vous
aurez tout le temps de parler sur ces
300 sous amendement sans qu'il y ait une
suspension de séance pour voir si en
effet c'est compliqué et si on ne peut
pas parler avec 300 sous amendement moi
je ne suis pas favorable mais ce n'est
pas moi qui décide
monsieur le Président Gontard pour me
rappeler au règlement
moi je voudrais juste remettre peut-être
les choses les choses à l'endroit parce
que oui non mais on est sur on est sur
des sujets on est sur des sujets
particulièrement importants que ça soit
l'article 7 maintenant ce qu'on va
aborder sur l'article 8 on nous accuse
enfin c'est votre petit jeu depuis un
petit un petit moment oui sur de
l'obstruction sur de l'obstruction si je
peux parler
sur de l'obstruction il me semble qu'on
a commencé le texte on avait 3500 3000
3600 amendements global que vous vous en
avez un peu plus de 1000 où est
l'obstruction on a fait notre travail
d'amendement moi ça me choque pas
absolument pas que sur un sujet comme
celui-là
que l'ensemble des sénatrices et des
sénateurs est déposer un amendement et
je suis même étonné qui est pas 348
amendements parce que on représente
chacun nos territoires et je peux vous
dire que dans nos territoires l'ensemble
de ces spécificités l'ensemble de ces
retours sur la vie des gens le fait de
passer sur l'article 7 de 62 à 64 ans
moi je l'entends sur mon territoire et
j'ai envie de m'exprimer parce que on me
demande de m'exprimer et c'est ça la
réalité du Parlement c'est cette réalité
là et c'est cette réalité là que vous
n'y est dangereusement dangereusement
parce que à travers ça vous nier la
démocratie alors s'il vous plaît
n'inversez pas les choses n'inversez pas
les choses
un article 38 l'article 42 qui fait que
effectivement quand on remet en question
quand on vous redéposez un amendement
qui est réécrit mais qui veut dire la
même chose quel autre possibilité nous
avons que deux sous amendes donc
n'inversez pas les choses on a eu des
débats intéressants serein jusque
l'article 7 pourquoi vous ne souhaitez
pas poursuivre sur cette voie là on est
à la moitié du texte on est à l'article
8 il nous reste encore du temps des
bâtons et des bâtons de l'ensemble des
amendements merci
[Applaudissements]
je dois consulter le Sénat sur cette
demande étant entendu que si l'examen
séparé est adopté par le Sénat nous
ferons une suspension qui permettra aux
collègues de revoir l'ordre de
préparation de leurs interventions
madame Gréau vous souhaitez vous
exprimer avant ce vote simple sur la
procédure je vais m'exprimer également
merci monsieur le Président vous
accélérez la procédure mais pour
répondre aux nombreuses observations sur
le fait que nous faisons de
l'obstruction sur ce projet de réforme
je voulais simplement vous dire que le
groupe communiste que nous sommes malgré
qu'ils ne soient pas grand en taille il
travaille il travaille dur et en toute
sérénité ne croyez pas que le nombre
d'amendements sert à faire de
l'obstruction vous serez dans l'erreur
nous avons déjà prouvé notre efficacité
je vais vous prendre un exemple dernier
en date je vous rappelle que la
commission d'enquête sur l'influence des
cabinets conseils dont vous connaissez
les résultats connus et reconnus sont de
notre initiative alors permettez-nous de
donner nos points de vue sur les effets
collatéraux que cette réforme va
engendrer nous défendons ce que nous
trouvons injuste et c'est pour c'est
pour cela que nous sommes élus merci
Monsieur kerouche sur la demande de
scrutin séparé
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
nous sommes frontalement
structurellement en opposition sur ce
sur ce texte frontalement il y a une
division forte entre la droite et la
majorité gouvernementale qui
n'appartiennent plus maintenant qu'un
même groupe et les bandes et les bancs
et les bancs de la gauche mais
je m'étonne que vous vous étonniez vous
mettez en place au sein de cette
Assemblée l'ensemble des procédures de
parlementarisme rationalisé que vous
pouvez mettre en place pour faire en
sorte de réduire notre temps de parole
et vous vous étonnez et vous vous
étonnez et vous vous étonnez donc que
nous réagissions par tous les par tous
les moyens disponibles c'est
relativement c'est relativement étonnant
nous prendrons et nous mettrons en œuvre
tous les moyens dont nous disposons
parce que vous avez choisi parce que
vous avez choisi du d'utiliser la
brutalité c'est votre choix c'est votre
choix initial et tout à l'heure
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure ou hier le
président Marseille a dit que les
mouches avaient changé d'âne je vous
rappelle cette citation je vous rappelle
cette citation latine azinos azzinum
fricate l'âne fréquente l'âne à
médiocrité médiocrité ennemie
[Applaudissements]
je consulte le Sénat qui est pour
l'examen séparé après madame après
qui est pour l'examen séparé
qui est contre
qui s'abstient l'examen séparé est
adopté nous suspendons jusqu'à 12h30
12h30
et le Sénat qui suspend sont un examen
de l'article 8 de la réforme des
retraites article 8 qui concerne
notamment le dispositif carrière longue
de départ anticipé pour les Français qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt avec de
nouvelles tensions justement autour de
cet article 8 pour en parler on va
retrouver Steve Jordan qui a suivi ses
échanges un petit peu où le ces
dernières minutes dans l'hémicycle Steve
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé oui vous avez
aimé l'article 7 alex je sais vous allez
adorer l'article 8 qui nous réserve
comme on l'a vu quelques étincelles
quelques étincelles même latines on l'a
entendu à quelques instants avec le
sénateur socialiste kerouche alors on a
commencé l'article 8 il y a à peu près
une heure cet article 8 porte sur les
départs anticipés c'est à dire sur ces
personnes qui ont travaillé qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt sur ces
carrières longues comment faire pour que
ces personnes ne soient pas pénalisées
par la retraite à 64 ans c'est tout
l'objet du débat on l'a entendu la
gauche qui a commencé par dénoncer
l'inégalité de traitement dont
seront victimes ces personnes avec la
réforme du gouvernement et la droite
aussi qui souhaitent et bien adoucir les
mesures prévues par le gouvernement
notamment en ce qui concerne les maires
de famille faut le savoir aussi que le
gouvernement a déjà procédé à quelques
conseils lors du passage du texte à
l'Assemblée nationale notamment face aux
demandes du groupe LR du député Aurélien
Pradier le député LR Aurélien Pradier
avoir jusqu'où est prêt à aller le
gouvernement aujourd'hui le Sénat qui
s'est donc emparé de cette question des
carrières longues cette question qui a
et bien suscité beaucoup d'opposition
qui suscitent en tout cas beaucoup
d'incompréhension chez un certain nombre
de Français Alex
effectivement Steve le Sénat qui donc
commence l'examen de cet article 8 sur
les carrières longues un examen qui
commence de manière assez tendue après
que ce matin elle a le droit de
sénatoriale est décidé de reporter le
débat sur l'amendement de Bruno
Retailleau qui voulait accélérer la
suppression des régimes spéciaux qui est
prévu par cette réforme des retraites
alors aujourd'hui les débats des
sénateurs devraient être consacrés à
cette article 8 sur les carrières
longues qui effectivement a fait l'objet
de tractation entre le gouvernement et
les républicains dans ce débat sur la
réforme des retraites notamment dans le
débat sur l'Assemblée nationale et
Isabelle borne la première ministre qui
a concédé des améliorations de ce
dispositif pour satisfaire les
républicains et notamment Aurélien
Pradier le député avec et bien une
nouvelle borne d'âge qui va être
introduite dans ce dispositif carrière
longue on le rappelle à la base une
réforme des retraites introduit trois
bornes d'âge pour des départs anticipés
pour ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt avancez-en avant 18 ans et avant 20
ans et la première ministre a prévu et
bien une nouvelle borne d'âge avant 21
ans cette nouvelle borne sera défendue
par un amendement du sénateur de la
majorité présidentielle Xavier yakovelli
et il devrait être examiné normalement
cet après-midi ou dans la soirée après
le fameux amendement de surcotte des
pensions pour les maires de famille qui
est défendu par la droite sénatoriale
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
spéciale ce matin consacré au débat sur
la réforme des retraites au Sénat je
vous donne rendez-vous à 14h30 en direct
sur Public Sénat pour continuer à suivre
les débats des débats que vous pouvez
également suivre sur notre site internet
public sénat.fr avec de très bons
articles très pédagogiques voilà très
bonne suite des programmes sur Public
Sénat
[Musique]